Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 224, das heute live gesendet wird aus der Marienstraße 11 aus Berlin, aus dem Berliner Chaos Computer Club. Das heißt, wenn ihr jetzt gerade eingeschaltet habt, kommt lieber her, seid dabei. Es gibt noch ein paar freie Plätze, nur noch ganz wenige. Es gibt eine riesige Menge, die macht jetzt Applaus. Ja, und wir sind heute hier zusammengekommen und um über ein Thema zu sprechen, was ich gar nicht verstehe. Also ich moderiere das Chaosradio schon seit einer Weile und es ist so, alle Themen, die hier behandelt werden, hab ich wenigstens schon mal gehört. Ich verstehe mal mehr oder weniger, aber immer noch genug, um Fragen stellen zu können. Und jetzt dieses, was wir heute machen, das ist also I'm at a total loss. Es ist nicht Quantenkryptographie, was ähnlich ist. Es ist auch nicht deutsches Steuerrecht. Es handelt sich um Amateurfunk. Und dazu sind jede Menge Leute da, die also noch komischere Namen haben als sonst. Herzlich willkommen.
Hallo, hier ist Lars oder auch mit dem Berufszeichen Delta Charlie 4 Lima Whisky.
Und der Florian Delta Lima 7 Mike Tango X-Ray.
Und der Matthias, der Delta Delta 4 Mike Delta.
Und live aus Amerika die Fabienne, die Kilo 7 Foxtrot Papa.
So, und mit denen möchte ich heute ein bisschen über Amateurfunk reden. Wir werden unter anderem auch klären, warum das ein Thema ist, das im Chaosradio behandelt wird. Ich möchte, also ich möchte jetzt damit anfangen, was meine Verbindung zu Funken ist, weil ich das letzte Mal davon gehört habe. Und zwar war ich also vielleicht ein Meter 40 groß. Und da gab es so eine Buchreihe, die hieß, also es war so TKKG-Style, die Funkfüchse. Und das waren halt ähnlich alberne Kinderdetektivgeschichten, die immer dann dadurch gelöst wurden, dass sie ein Funkgerät dabei hatten und dann im passenden Moment noch irgendjemanden angefunkt haben. Und die andere Verbindung, die ich dazu hatte, war der Film Ein ausgekochtes Schlitzohr mit Burt Reynolds. Irgendso ein Roadmovie-Haste-Ding, wo er mit einem, also sein Freund fährt im Truck und er fährt in so einem super schnittigen Ami-Schlitten. Und dann haben die auch so Funkgeräte und dann funken die mehr gegenseitig und machen damit die Polizei, setzen sich auch mal ab. Und es war alles total geil. Und ich war so, so angefeuert davon, dass ich mir dann irgendwann von meinem langen, zusammengesparten Taschengeld ein CB-Funkgerät gekauft habe. War da ein bisschen enttäuschend, ein Freund hatte das auch. Wir wohnten irgendwie fünf Kilometer auseinander, haben dann mal durchlaufen festgestellt, das reicht ungefähr 1, 5 Kilometer und dann verrotte das Ding in einer Schublade. Dann kam ein Computer, das Internet und ich habe nie wieder über Funkgeräte gehört. Und dann sagen auf einmal Leute, Amateurfunk, das ist das große Ding, das muss man machen. Es gibt im Chaos Computer Club Berlin sogar Kurse, wo man das lernen kann. Und ich frage mich, wie kommt man denn so, also grob in den 2000er Jahren auf die Idee, freiwillig zu funken? Herr DTX17988364, Lars.
Delta Charlie 4 Lima Whisky, immer noch für dich. Du kannst dich auch Lars nennen, Lima Alpha Rumia Sierra. Ja, das ist tatsächlich so. Bei Funk, da geht man dann die Namen nochmal so durch, damit man es besser versteht einfach und dann buchstabiert man die. Ja, was ist das? Was du hattest, war CB Funk. Um ganz ehrlich zu sagen, ich habe auch mit CB Funk angefangen. Das war in den späten 90ern. Da hatte ich auch so ein CB Funk Gerät, mit ein paar Freunden auch das Ganze gehabt, mit dem Auto eingebaut, konnten auch miteinander quatschen. Wir konnten zum Kongress fahren, vom CCC halt, und konnten dann mit mehreren Fahrzeugen untereinander sprechen. Das ist natürlich auch eine Art des Amateurfunks, ist aber ein wenig anders. Also Amateurfunk bin halt dazu quasi alles, was irgendwie, ja, Funken aus Spaß ist. Bei CB Funk liegt es einfach daran, du kaufst ein Gerät.
Nicht die Technik. Wie bist du dazu gekommen, das zu machen?
Ich überfreunde auch einfach tatsächlich. Und dann irgendwie ein paar Jahre später, beziehungsweise auch schon so bei den ersten Kongressen, weil ich war Ende der 90er, habe ich Amateurfunker getroffen. Und die durften ein wenig mehr machen mit Funk, anstatt nur diese CB Funkgeräte zu benutzen. Die durften auch selbst bauen. Und das hat mich dann so ein bisschen angekitzelt. Dann habe ich vor zehn Jahren dann mal meine sogenannte Amateurfunk-Lizenz gemacht.
Die durften im Sinne von, die hatten da eine besondere Sondergenehmigung oder die durften, weil die hatten sie einfach mehr Wissen drauf geschafft?
Weil die eine Sondergenehmigung haben.
Aha, dazu kommen wir noch.
Genau.
Ich war wahrscheinlich 14, 15 oder so was. Und ein Bekannter hatte halt ein Amateurfunkgerät in seinem Auto eingebaut. Und hat mir dann so ein bisschen gezeigt, wie das mit diesen Relais funktioniert und was man da so machen kann. Das war so die erste Berührung. Und dann wollte ich das immer irgendwie machen. Und das ist aber dann so 10, 15 Jahre nicht passiert. Oder länger. Wesentlich länger. Und dann war halt jetzt hier irgendwie im Club einen Kurs angesetzt mit Lars. Und dann hat sich das Ergebnis gesagt, jetzt mache ich das mal. Und ja, auch so eine Faszination heraus, dass man mit einem sehr einfachen Gerät, dass man im Zweifelsfall auch selber bauen kann und die ganze Welt funken kann, ohne irgendwelche Stationen dazwischen zu haben. Also vollkommen unabhängig von irgendwelchen Firmen.
Das ist doch auch mit Voice-over-IP.
Ja, also in Deutschland gerade nicht, wenn man bei Kabel Deutschland ist, weil das ist gerade ausgefallen.
Oder wenn man mobil mit Modafone unterwegs ist, das ist auch gerade ausgefallen, aber gut.
Ja, also diese Ausfälle sorgen halt dafür, dass es dann eben gerade eben nicht immer geht.
Verstehe. Matthias, wie bist du zum Funken gekommen?
Ja, das ist eigentlich ganz schön. Ich war letztes Jahr auf dem Chaos Communication Congress und da wurde so ein kleines Device ausgeteilt, ein kleines Radio-Batch. Das ist ein sogenanntes Software-defined Radio. Und damit wusste ich erst mal nichts anzufangen.
Da geht's dir wie mir. Also es ist quasi ein Bausatz und mit dem kann man dann auch funken.
Richtig. Also das ist im Prinzip dieses lustige kleine Device, was einen Antennenanschluss hat und ein bisschen Elektronik drauf und ein kleines Display.
Darf ich es mal kurz haben? Wenn ihr sowas live sehen wollt, kommt live in den Club Marienstraße 11. Wir senden hier von hier und da kann man auch alles gucken. Also es sieht aus wie ein viel zu dickes Smartphone mit noch einer Antenne, aber es ist anscheinend ein kleines Funkgerät.
Richtig, also und da ich damals von Funken soweit noch nichts verstand und auch keine Idee hatte, was man damit jetzt machen könnte und vor allem wie das Ganze funktioniert, wurd es sich an, dass halt Lars gerade eben dann auch in kurzer Zeit danach einen Kurs im Club eben angeboten hat und da habe ich mich dann dazu gesetzt und habe dann daran teilgenommen und dieses Jahr dann auch meine Lizenz gemacht.
Okay, also meine derzeitige Theorie, warum es Funken noch gibt, ist, Lars hat alle angesteckt. Fabienne, wie bist du zum Funken gekommen?
Bisschen durch Lars, aber auch durch Travis Goodspeed und durch meine Opa. Meine Opa war Foxtrot 8 Charlie Whiskey und der war sehr aktiv in Frankreich, sehr früh und ich hatte so immer in meiner Familie gehört, so Geschichten von meinem Vater, wie meine Opa, so irgendwas mit Amateurfunk gemacht, so jeden Tag. Und ich hatte so viele Interesse über SDR, natürlich bin Hardware Hackerin und ich habe viel mit SDR gespielt und ich habe meine eigene Antenne gebaut und dann habe ich gedacht, das ist blöd nur zu hören, ich will auch sprechen und ich will auch senden und dann habe ich so Amateurfunk-Lizenz gemacht.
Ok, Fabienne, mal abgesehen davon, dass man noch basteln kann, wir kommen noch später dazu, was SDR genau ist und dass es halt irgendwie Spaß macht zu sprechen. Hat Funken heutzutage auch noch einen praktischen Nutzen?
Ja, für mich persönlich, mein Mann und ich, wir haben Amateurfunkgeräte im Auto und in Washington State, wir haben kein Recht im Handy zu reden, wenn wir im Auto sind, aber wir haben das Recht Amateurfunk zu reden. Und wir haben Antennen, so Magmount-Antennen mit Magneten drauf auf dem Auto und es klappt super gut.
Okay, überlass es den Amis, selbst einmal Gesetze zu erfinden.
Das ist ja auch so.
Das ist ja auch so, man kann auch eine Freisprechanlage benutzen.
Du kannst eine Freisprechanlage benutzen fürs Handy, klar, aber am Amateurfunk darfst du auch das Handmikrofon in der Hand halten und benutzen. Darfst du gar morsen, wenn du das Auto fährst.
Na, wenn du es kannst.
Du darfst ein technisches Gerät in der Hand halten und Knöpfe drücken.
Das ist korrekt, weil es kein Telefon ist.
Du darfst nur nicht während des Autofahrens telefonieren.
Du kannst auch alte Zähnetz-Telefone, die früher im Auto verbaut waren, auf Amateurfunk umbauen und dann darfst du es auch benutzen, wenn er fährt.
Aber woher kommt das? Es ist einfach nur eine Gesetzeslücke, wo keiner drüber nachgedacht hat?
Es gibt dazu ein Urteil und das heißt einfach, das Funken ist nicht so anstrengend wie Telefonieren.
Bitte was?
Das heißt, man wird nicht so stark abgelenkt?
Könnt ihr bitte noch mal eure Rufnamen sagen?
Delta Charlie 4 Lima Whisky.
Delta Lima 7 Mark Tango 2.
Delta Delta 4 Mark Delta.
Aber das ist doch Quatsch.
Du hast beim Amateurfunk... Wir kommen da vielleicht nachher noch ein bisschen zu. Beim Amateurfunk darfst du dich im Prinzip nicht über alles unterhalten, worüber du dich unterhalten möchtest. Und bist im Prinzip so ein bisschen auf mehr oder weniger belanglose Kommunikation zwischen Amateurfunk-Teilnehmern oder zwischen Funk-Amateuren beschränkt.
Beliebt das auch Meta-Kommunikation?
Es gibt da zwei Hintergedanken, warum man dieses Urteil so ein bisschen sich vielleicht herleiten kann. Das eine ist, wenn ich funken verbiete, dann dürften auch alle Krankenwagen und LKWs und so weiter das auch nicht mehr machen.
Für die könnte man natürlich keine Sondergenehmigung.
Und die andere Sache ist, die sagt jemand, der ausgebildeter Amateurfunker ist, beziehungsweise Funk-Amateur, hat da so viel Erfahrung, dass er das einfach nebenbei macht. Und du guckst nicht damit auf das Display und du bist nicht so tief im Gespräch drin. Ich glaube, die Formulierung war auch, du kannst das Gespräch jederzeit unterbrechen und bist nicht wie bei einem Telefonat so tief im Gespräch drin, dass du einfach das Funkgerät oder das Telefon fallen lässt, weil du ja eine Verpflichtung hast, deinem Gesprächspartner zu beantworten. Und beim Funken ist jedem klar, dass du es jederzeit abbrechen kannst. Das ist so ein bisschen der Hintergedanke dahinter.
Mit Verlaub, das halte ich für großen Blödsinn. Aber wir sind ja heute nicht hier zusammengekommen über Rechtsprechung und Autofahren, wo ich das wirklich sehr, sehr lustig finde zu sprechen, sondern über das Amateurfunk. Bevor wir drüber sprechen, was das... Ich tue es noch ein bisschen, es gibt eine Prüfung. Man hat eine ordentliche Berufsbezeichnung anscheinend. Aber was sind denn eigentlich die technischen Grundlagen? Wie funktioniert dieses Funkding? Ich habe gerade erzählt, bei mir hat es damals 1, 5 Kilometer gereicht, aber anscheinend funktioniert das auch besser.
Das glaube ich irgendwie nicht. Bist du so sicher, dass das ein CB-Funkgerät war?
Es wurde beim Versandhändler so benahmst.
Vielleicht war es ein kleines Walkie-Talkie mit einer 4, 5 Volt Batterie drin, was man damals dazu gekriegt hat.
Weil CB-Funk geht eigentlich auch deutlich weiter. Es sind 20, 30 Kilometer überhaupt kein Problem.
Meistens oder ab und zu auch bei Atlantik. Das geht auch mit CB-Funk. Was sind die Grundlagen? Du fragst es danach. Funken gibt es ja eigentlich noch gar nicht so lange. Es gab ja früher Telegrafenstrecken. Das heißt, dass dann Leitungen gezogen wurden, über die dann gemorst wurde. Das waren die ersten Kommunikationswege über lange Strecken, wo jetzt nicht ein Boote auf schnellen Schuhen oder mit dem Pferd durch die Gegend reiten musste. Dann gab es dann so Entwicklungen, die technischen Grundlagen, die Maxwell und Hertz entwickelt haben, über Marconi, der die erste Antenne gebaut hatte, um dann Signale durch die Gegend zu schicken. Das heißt, wirklich über die Luftschnittstelle gesehen, ein Signal rüberzuschicken. Das erste, was da gebaut wurde, waren sogenannte Knallfunken-Sender. Die konnten nur an- und aus. Das reicht aber für Morsen aus. Da kann man lang und kurz drüber senden. Das geht dann schon damit. Dann kam es zu der kompletten Weiterentwicklung, dass auch Sprache übertragen werden kann, später Bilder übertragen werden können. Das geht momentan so. Ich glaube, 890 rum waren die ersten Gerätschaften, die über Funk Daten übermitteln konnten.
Warum hat das aufgehört? Es hat keine weite Verbreitung.
Wo hast du heutzutage Funk? Nimm mal dein Telefon in die Hand und schau mal drauf, wie viele verschiedene Antennen du da dran hast.
Das ist nicht das, was ich meinte. Das dürfte auch klar gewesen sein, sondern diese bestimmte Art.
Du meinst Amateurfunk tatsächlich selbst. Amateurfunk geht es immer auf und ab. Also in Deutschland dürfen wir eh erst seit dem 2. Weltkrieg, zumindest in Westdeutschland, Amateurfunk betreiben. Das war vorher ziemlich stark eingeschränkt, da die Post meinte, sie hätte eine Hoheit auf Datenübermittlungen. Dann hat sie gesagt, so Leute, die Inhalte austauschen, das wollen wir nicht haben. Dementsprechend hat sie das erst nach dem 2. Weltkrieg entwickelt in Deutschland, dass Leute halt funken konnten. Das war damals schönes Hobby, um dann wirklich zu kommunizieren. Telefon war noch nicht so stark ausgebaut. Dann fing es in den 70er Jahren an, 1975, der CB-Funk. Der wurde dann freigegeben. Das heißt, man brauchte keine Lizenz machen, konnte sich ein Gerät kaufen, konnte es hinstellen, konnte es nutzen. Das war dann der erste Einschlag für Amateurfunk, dass da nicht mehr so ein Interesse groß war. Dann gab es Anfang der 90er oder Mitte der 90er die ersten Handys, dass dann Mobilfunk betrieben werden konnte. So konnte ich direkt kommunizieren, da brauchte ich dann auch keinen Amateurfunk mehr. Ende der 90er, Anfang 2000, der Internet. Das gab auch noch mal so einen Einschnitt. So ab 2003 gab es dann irgendwie DSL für 40 Euro im Monat. Dann gab es auch nicht mehr so ein großes Interesse dran. Und jetzt kommt es langsam gefühlt wieder, so seit 3, 4 Jahren, tatsächlich über technische Entwicklungen, dass wieder sehr viel Selbstbau gemacht wird, sehr viel in eigene Geräte rein investiert wird, bzw. gebastelt wird. Und das Interesse einfach da groß ist, um irgendwie das zu verstehen und selbst zu bauen.
Aber da geht es schon eher darum, es gibt zu sagen, also Amateurfunk, da sind tendenziell schon auch Leute, die das nicht nur wegen des Funkens an sich machen, sondern auch immer wegen der dahinterliegenden Technik und der etwas des arkanen Erringens einer Lizenz oder seiner Erprobung.
Wie war die Prüfungsfrage? Amateurfunk ist ein Funkdienst zwischen Funkamateuren aus persönlicher Neigung, technischem und wissenschaftlichem Interesse und nicht kommerziell.
Das ist die Definition nach Gesetz. Da müssen wir mal die Ionosphäre fragen. Heißt? Ja, tatsächlich. Ist so ein schöner Spruch. Ich glaube, den hat Travis auch genannt. Travis Goodsbyt, von dem Fabienne gerade schon mal gesprochen hatte. Hemradio, wie es im Englischen heißt, Amateurradio. So in diese Richtung rein. Das heißt, wenn ich mein Funkgerät aufbaue, meine Antenne aufbaue, ich rufe einfach ins Funkgerät rein, auf irgendeiner Frequenz, und gucke einfach mal, wer antwortet, wenn ich mich vorher mit irgendjemand verabredet habe. Dann entscheidet so ein bisschen die Ionosphäre auch darüber, wie die Funkwellen sich über die Erde ausbreiten. Die werden an den Luftschichten bzw. an den verschiedenen Schichten um die Erde herum reflektiert und können sich darüber ausbreiten. Das ist ganz unterschiedlich. Je nach Sonnenflecken tatsächlich, je nach Jahreszeit auch, je nach sonstigen atmosphärischen Störungen. Tageszeit natürlich auch ganz stark, das ist immer davon abhängig. Frequenz kommt auch noch alles hinzu.
Wie funktioniert das? Ich nehme das Funkgerät, das läuft auf einer bestimmten Frequenz, dann rufe ich in den Erdhörer rein und dann kann jeder der derselben Frequenzhörer antworten.
Es gibt sogenannte Bandpläne, die festlegen, auf welchen Frequenzen man senden darf, dass man sich nicht gegenseitig stört, dass man sich nicht irgendwelche kommerziellen Anbieter von Taxifunk z.B. stört oder irgendwelche Radiosender. Wenn ich im Kurzwellenbereich bin, habe ich eine Antenne, die ich dann z.B. schräg gegen den Himmel richte. Dann bounce das von der Ionosphäre ab und geht zur Erde und wieder nach oben. Irgendwo trifft es hoffentlich auf die Antenne von jemandem anderen, der das dann auch hören kann. Der kann mehr antworten.
Das heißt, es gibt immer nur einen, der dich hört, und es gibt mehrere?
Es gibt vielleicht nur einen, vielleicht auch mehrere. Das kommt auf das Zufallsprinzip dann drauf an. Und es kann sein, dass jemand, der 400 oder 1.000 km weit weg ist, dein Signal empfängt. Und jemand, der 20 km weit weg ist, es schon nicht mehr empfängt, weil er gerade im Schatten ist von dieser Reflektion. Oder in 800 km ist es gerade nicht mehr empfängt.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, ich schieße ein Laser in den Himmel, und an dem Inuasferenspiegel wird er wieder runter. Es gibt wirklich einen Punkt, wo das hintrifft. Man stellt sich bei Funkfällen vor, die breiten sich kreisförmig aus.
Das machen sie auch. Das Problem ist, die Erde ist halt rund. Das heißt, es geht bis zum Horizont, und dann vielleicht noch ein bisschen weiter.
Das ist die sogenannte Bodenwelle?
Genau, die Bodenwelle breitet sich ebenso auf den Boden aus. So heißt das deswegen auch. Aber das geht nur bis knapp hinter dem Horizont. Dann hört es auf, weil die Erde halt rund ist. Und die Raumwelle wird an der Inuasfere z.B. reflektiert. Da gibt es verschiedene Schichten. Und je nachdem, wie die geladen sind, reflektiert die eine mehr oder weniger oder dämpft auch irgendwelche Frequenzen.
Das normale UKW-Radio, also Ultra-Kurzwellen-Radio, da steht ja UKW, sprich alles, was wir zwischen 87, 5 und 108 MHz empfangen. Das ist eigentlich eine gradlinige Ausbreitung von diesen Wellen. Das heißt, die könnten wir eigentlich gar nicht auf großer Weitreiche empfangen. Meistens klappt das ja auch nur so in der Stadt und drum herum irgendwie. Wenn ich mit dem Auto fahre, merke ich ja irgendwie, nach 100 Kilometern ist der Sender weg einfach. Da kriege ich die nicht mehr rein. Aber es gibt dann halt auch so Momente, zum Beispiel, wenn gerade mal so ein Föhn über die Alten hinüberfegt, dass dann sich entsprechende Luftschichten auch bilden.
Sogenannte sporadische E-Schichten.
Genau, und an diesen Schichten kann es dann auch einfach mal vorkommen, dass dort die Wellen reflektiert werden. Es kann also sein, dass du in Bayern plötzlich ein Radiosender aus Italien hörst, obwohl die Alten dazwischen sind.
Was ist denn jetzt, würde ich gerne von euch wissen, mal die weiteste Entfernung, die ich jemals gesprochen habe, Fabienne? Was ist der weit entfernteste Funker, den du jemals am Gerät hattest, falls man das so sagt?
Ich, wenn ich in Tennessee war, habe ich viele Leute in Europa gehört und in Russland.
Und ist das dann so, man hört das und um den Rekord zu halten, sagt man, okay, das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich, aber eigentlich ist die Verbindung ganz schlecht, oder kann man sich da wirklich unterhalten?
Wir haben uns kurz unterhalten und unsere Namen gesagt und wie gut das Signal sich gehört. Und dann, wenn man nett ist, dann schickt man so eine Postkarte an die Leute, dass du mitgesprochen hast.
Aha, ist das, vorhin kam ja gerade, man darf nur über bestimmte Sachen reden. Darfst du quasi nicht über mehr reden oder wie läuft das?
Doch, aber manchmal gibt es so eine genannte Pile-Up. Das bedeutet, es gibt viele Leute, die mit den Leuten weit weg reden. Und man hört alle die anderen Leute, die versuchen mit den Personen in Europa oder den Personen in den USA zu reden.
Lars, was war dein weitest entferntes?
Neuseeland, das ist von Europa aus tatsächlich um die Erde herum die weiteste Entfernung.
Und hast du da auch nur Rufnamen ausgetauscht und eine Postkarte hingeschickt?
Auch nur eben schnell Rufzeichen ausgetauscht. Das reicht auch aus, um eine Funkeverwendung hingekriegt zu haben.
Okay, anscheinend setzt sich ein Missverständnis auf. Ich dachte ja, man benutzt dieses Funken, um miteinander zu kommunizieren. Aber jetzt kommt es mir eher vor wie so eine Art Geocaching, ohne sich zu bewegen. Man erreicht eine bestimmte Stelle und wenn man die erreicht hat, lässt man sich sozusagen sagen, ich habe dich erreicht und schicke dir meine Postkarte.
Du fragst nach der weitesten Verbindung. Bei weiten Verbindungen tauscht man tatsächlich nur eben schnell Namen aus. Die Verbindungsstärke ab und zu noch mal ein bisschen mehr. Wie gerade das Wetter ist, ist auch mal ganz praktisch, um zu wissen, wie gut man sich ausbreiten kann. Aber meist will ich ja nur testen, wie weit meine Antenne geht, die ich mal selbst gebaut habe.
Ist das quasi so eine Art Sport auch? Also wenn man Funken betreibt, macht man ab und zu, setzt man sich hin und sagt, und jetzt gucke ich mal, wie weit ich komme?
Es gibt da auch Contest, wo es darum geht, in möglichst kurzer Zeit möglichst viele Stationen zu erreichen. Und dann beschränkt man sich eben wirklich in diesem sogenannten QSO, also in dem kurzen Gespräch, das man da führt. Das gibt es für alles so kurz zur Abkürzung. Das kommt aus dem Morsen, da können wir vielleicht nachher auch nochmal drauf eingehen. In so einem QSO beschränkt man sich wirklich darauf, die wichtigsten Informationen zu bemitteln. Das heißt, wie ist mein Rufzeichen, von wo aus rufe ich, vielleicht noch den Namen kurz zu sagen, also den Vornamen, und durchzugeben, in welcher Qualität man die andere Station empfängt. Und das bekommt man von der Gegenseite auch, dann schreibt man das jeweils auf. Und durch die QSL-Karte bestätigt man die Funkverbindungen in beide Richtungen. Und dafür bekommt man, wenn es ein Contest war, dann eben auch Punkte.
Aber um nochmal kurz darauf zurückzukommen, was ist die weiteste Verbindung? Das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt um die Erde herum, sondern das war bei mir halt einmal Erde, Mond, Erde. Also so eine Verbindung, dass ich halt von Erde aus auf den Mond geschossen habe, der Mond reflektiert hat und wieder zurückgeschickt hat. Also das sind dann auch mal ganz locker 380.000 mal 2 Kilometer.
Entschuldigung, was hast du da für Antennen? Laserkanonen?
Ja, fast. Also die sind schon 4 Meter lang und als sogenannte Doppeljagi-Antenne ausgebildet. Und dann schickst du da auch mal 500 Watt drauf und dann kommt das auch irgendwo wieder an.
Er soll das halt nicht unbedingt direkt daneben stehen. Oder direkt davor.
Vor dem Strahl daneben geht es schon, aber nicht vor. Das sind dann auch so die Gründe, warum man tatsächlich für solche Sachen Prüfungen haben möchte. Dazu kommen wir nachher.
Was war deine weiteste Funkverbindung?
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen unfair, weil Kurzfeld habe ich bisher noch nicht machen können. Weil im 7. Stock im Hochhaus ist das immer schlecht, eben wegen der Leistung, die man da raushauen muss eventuell. Außer man macht jetzt wirklich nur Mausen, was ich noch nicht kann. Und ansonsten bin ich halt nur so im Stadtbereich unterwegs. Wenn man nicht den Spezialfall Echolink nehmt, den wir nachher auch noch erklären, da habe ich mit jemandem aus Russa gesprochen.
Ja, so ungefähr 60 Kilometer. Das ist natürlich auch... Ich mache halt hauptsächlich da diesen Quasselfunk auf 70 Zentimeter bzw. 2 Meter. Und das war dann beim Wandern. Da habe ich südlich von Berlin so einen kleinen Aussichtsturm erklommen und habe dann von da aus ein QSO über das Spandau Relais mit jemandem, der gerade auch irgendwo im Auto saß, gemacht. Und das war so ungefähr Luftlinie, 60 Kilometer, aber...
Jetzt ist schon ein paar Mal das Wort Relais gefallen. Schaffen wir es noch, vor dem ersten Break zu erklären, was das soll?
Drück doch mal auf diese Pieptaste.
Auf diese Pieptaste, also...
Wir haben da mal was vorbereitet.
Ich habe ein paar Sachen mitgebracht. Welche genau soll ich denn jetzt mal zu Gehör bringen?
1750 und dann vielleicht DB0BLO.
Dieses? Was zur Hölle?
Das war ein Relais.
Was ist ein Relais?
Das Problem ist, wenn du mit so einem kleinen Handfunkgerät, ich halte das für einen Streamer gerade hoch, das hat so ungefähr für eine Ausgangsleistung, Wendeleistung, damit kommt man nicht so richtig weit. Was heißt das?
Ja doch, 60 Kilometer.
Wenn du aber in der Stadt unterwegs bist, mit Häusern dazwischen, ist das alles sehr unpraktisch oder mit dem Auto unterwegs bist. Und deswegen hat man sich die Idee, hat man die Idee bekommen, dass man so genannte Relais baut. Das heißt, ich habe zwei Frequenzen, ich mache das Funkgerät an und sende auf einer Eingabefrequenz, so heißt das Ding, diesen Ton, den wir eben zuerst gehört haben, das sind 1750 Hertz aus, das Relais empfängt den, schaltet sich dann daraufhin ein und gibt auf der Ausgabefrequenz, das ist eine andere Frequenz, das wieder aus, was ich auf der Eingabefrequenz hinsende, und zwar von dem erhöhten Standpunkt und mit mehr Leistung, als ich das von dem Handwunkgerät machen kann.
Und diese beiden Frequenzen, die weiß man vorher?
Die weiß man vorher.
Die sind üblicherweise bei 70 Zentimeter z.B. 7, 6 MHz drunter oder bei 2 Meter sind es 600 KHz.
Das heißt, ich habe eine Eingabefrequenz, die weiß ich, da gibt es halt Listen zu, und die Ausgabefrequenz ist entsprechend höher in dem Fall. Man empfängt eben auf der Ausgabefrequenz des Relais und sendet auf der Eingabefrequenz des Relais und hat dadurch eine Reichweitenerhöhung. Und damit kann ich halt im gesamten Stadtgebiet alle erreichen, die auf diesem Relais drauf sind und dazuhören.
Genau, und weil man dieses Relais selber über sein Funkgerät mit Hilfe von seinem sogenannten Auftaster und Fernsteher ist das Ganze eine ferngestehrte Funkstation.
Ver-stehe. Ich möchte als nächstes dann wirklich gerne wissen, was man reden darf und was man nicht reden darf. Das klären wir aber nach der ersten Musik in diesem Chaosradio 224 live aus der Marienstraße 11. Und die kommt passenderweise, heißt der Song The Other Side und ist von Luke Hasch.
Hier ist das Spannndauer Relais, bitte sprechen Sie.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück zum Chaosradio 224 über Amateurfunk. Was ihr gerade als letztes gehört habt, war ein Relais. Das ist so eine Art Verstärker, Weiterreichungsstation, die Funksignale aufnimmt und so weiter reicht, dass man sie auch viel weiter entfernt hören kann. Und wir sprechen heute mit Fabienne, Lars, Mutags und Matthias über Amateurfunk und was das ist, also wie es technisch funktioniert und warum man das macht. Haben wir gerade geklärt und haben zum letzten über Relays gesprochen, also diese Verstärkerfunktion. Ihr wolltet noch sagen, wie viel es da um Berlin herum gibt von den Situationen?
Also in Berlin rundherum acht, zwei noch, die gerade nicht betrieb sind, hab ich gehört.
Nicht so ganz.
Nicht so ganz und das gerade zuletzt war eins, was in der Nähe von Spandau eben steht. Vor der Pause hatten wir glaube ich eins in...
Das war Wunschhausen. Genau, richtig, das war DB0B.
Und gerade eben das war DB0SP.
Wer betreibt diese Dinger denn?
Oh, auch genau so Funkamateure, die einfach Spaß daran haben und so ein Ding halt hinstellen. Das ist dann ein Unterschied, die viele finanziert werden. Also manche gehen dann mit einem Hut rum und sammeln dann mal irgendwie Geld ein, so quasi. Andere lassen das über ein Verein laufen, das ist ganz unterschiedlich.
Okay, weil das... Also es ist ja wahrscheinlich nicht ganz billig. Ich hab ja gerade gesagt, irgendwie zum Mond braucht man 500 Watt. Ist so ein Relais vielleicht nicht ganz so...
Na die sind ungefähr mit 10 Watt raus, 10, 15 Watt. Mehr machen die normalerweise nicht. Das reicht aber auch, weil sie auf einem erhöhten Standort sind. Zum Beispiel auf einem Telekonditionsturm von der Post mit da drauf. Oder auf einem Funkmast von einem Mobilfunkanbieter oder so was mit drauf. Und im Prinzip braucht man nur zwei Funkgeräte und ein bisschen Hardware dazu. Zum Beispiel den Raspberry Pi tatsächlich.
Okay, das ist jetzt nicht so doll viel. Jetzt würde ich gerne mal hören, worüber man da eigentlich reden darf. Weil ich hab ja schon gesagt, man darf nicht über alles reden. Wenn man Ziele sehr weit weg anfunkt oder Leute, die begehrt sind, dann muss man sich kurz halten. Aber gleichzeitig hat Fabienne erzählt, sie nutzt es, weil man im Auto sprechen darf, was man halt mit Smartphones nicht darf. Fabienne, kannst du vielleicht mal erzählen, was darf man bei euch reden und was redest du tatsächlich?
Ja, in den USA muss man nicht, wie sagt man, swear words sagen. Aber das gehört zu, zum Beispiel in Los Angeles kannst du auch swear words damit so was mit sagen. Du kannst nicht singen, du kannst keine Musik haben, so kein Singen, keine Musik. Aber das sind amerikanische Regeln, ich glaube, die sind ein bisschen ähnlich in Deutschland. Aber das warum kein so schlechte Wort ist, weil Kinder kann auch Amateur funken und das gehört das zu.
Und ist es so, dass das Gespräch nur eine bestimmte Länge haben darf? Also ist es so, dass man den Kanal irgendwann wieder freiräumen muss? Oder wenn man sich sozusagen, wenn man spricht, dann darf man das auch erst mal machen?
Nein, ich habe so über HF geredet und HF, so diese High Frequency Hochfrequenz, so 20 Meter, 40 Meter. Wenn man so diese lange Strecke, manchmal spricht man sehr kurz, weil es gibt viele Leute, die mit den anderen Leuten reden will. Aber es gibt manchmal Leute, die reden, sie reden einfach so. Wie sind die Kinder? Ich habe vor einer Woche in Seattle gehört, jemand in Italien, der mit jemandem in Texas gesprochen hat. Die haben so sehr lange, so fünf Minuten gelabbert über irgendwas, so Familiengeschichten. Das ist auch keine feste Regel. Es gibt auch Freunde, die weit weg voneinander sind. Und wenn die Chance, miteinander zu reden, dann reden sie ein bisschen länger.
Okay, gibt es dann bestimmte Kanäle, die man dann dafür nimmt? Weil ihr habt ja gerade gesagt, zum Beispiel für Relays gibt es bestimmte Kanäle. Da würde man jetzt wahrscheinlich denken, da macht man es halt lieber nicht so lang. Oder muss man sich da irgendwie irgendwo hinbegeben?
Ja, deswegen ist die Bahnpläne da. Und sagt dir, wo du so reden soll, wo du morsen soll und wo du so neue Leute anrufen soll. Es gibt so bestimmte Frequenz dafür.
Also es gibt eine sogenannte Anruffrequenz. Es gibt auch internationale Anruffrequenzen. Und was man normalerweise macht, man sendet auf dieser Anruffrequenz einen allgemeinen Ruf aus. Und sobald jemand antwortet, verabredet man ihm eine Frequenz, auf die man wechselt, die hoffentlich auch frei ist. Da muss man eben kurz reinhören. Dann wechseln beide auf die neue Frequenz. Und dann kann man sich unterhalten. Und dann ist die andere Frequenz wieder frei. Und diese Dauer, es gibt in Deutschland zumindest die Geschichte, dass man so alle zehn Minuten sein Rufzeichen nennen sollte, damit klar ist, wer da spricht. Und dass man auch mal ab und zu Lücken lassen sollte, gerade auf Relais, damit andere Leute auch mal dazwischenkommen können und auch ihren Funkverkehr darüber aufwickeln können. Das ist einfach eine Sache der guten Sitte und der Höflichkeit. Bei der Rufzeichenennung, die steht, glaube ich, tatsächlich auch in den Vorschriften drin, dass die alle 10 Minuten zu erfreuen haben.
Gibt es da so eine Art Stop-Wort auch? Also wenn ich jetzt auf einen Kanal komme, wo zwei Leute stundenlang reden, dass ich da irgendwas reinkrähe?
Na, das mit dem Rein-Krähen wird halt schwierig. Wenn du weniger Leistung hast als die anderen, dann kommst du gar nicht dazwischen.
Das heißt aber auch, wenn ich mehr Leistung habe, dann...
Das heißt, wenn du mehr Leistung hast und wenn du ein zugelassener Amateurfunker bist, an einer festen Amateurfunkstelle bist, darfst du bis 1000 Watt aussenden.
750 in Deutschland. Kommt immer auf die Frequenz an.
Ja, kommt auf die Frequenz an.
Abrufwoche, könntest du, ihr habt jetzt die ganze Zeit 70 Zentimeter, 2 Meter, 40 Meter.
Da wollte ich noch einen Haken, Fabienne. Du hast ja was von 40 Metern gesprochen und dann von großer Entfernung. Die 40 Meter ist die Wellenlänge, also die Länge der Funkwelle im Raum. Und je länger die ist, die Funkwelle, umso weiter kommt man auch normalerweise weg. Das heißt, 40 Meter ist Kurzwelle. Und wenn wir jetzt hier auf 70 Zentimeter gehen, dann sind das eben so 433 Megahertz, 2 Meter sind ungefähr 144 Megahertz. Hat mit der Lichtflüssigkeit zu tun.
Ja, aber was hat das nochmal mit der Länge zu tun?
Also der Reichweite? Also je länger die Welle ist, das heißt, je geringer die Frequenz ist, umso höher ist die Reichweite der Funkausbreitung. Deswegen Langwellensender, die gehen sehr weit. Mittelwelle ist dazwischen. UKW geht halt wirklich nur so im Nahbereich.
Okay, das ist auch sozusagen eine große Zahl.
Und WLAN ist dann noch kleiner. Das sind 2, 4 Gigahertz oder 5 Gigahertz.
Na ja, UKW nutze ich auch, um gegen den Mond zu schießen.
Ja, aber da hast du Sichtverbindungen.
Da habe ich Sichtverbindungen, das ist vollkommen richtig.
Okay, warte mal. Also hohe Frequenz, kurze Reichweite.
Ja, so ganz grob gesehen, ja.
Grob reicht mir. Sehr gut. So jetzt kam die ganze Zeit ja schnell mal so, also Amateurfunk, die müssten halt seine Prüfung. Was genau, da wird dieses Funkzeichen eigentlich, wird es von offizieller Stelle vergeben oder darf ich mir das ausdenken?
Oh ja, das darf man sich ausdenken.
Wenn es noch frei ist, in einem bestimmten Rahmen.
Also der Landeskenner ist in der Regel vorne relativ fest, also da ist man zum Beispiel in Deutschland auf irgendetwas mit D und dann hat man eine ganze Latte an verschiedenen Weitungen gestorben. Sieht Torea hat auch D. Ja, richtig, richtig, das ab was kommt, ab was ist die Torea? Ja, genau, also man kann sich zum Beispiel Delta Delta oder Delta Lima irgendwie so etwas vorne ranstellen, das ist der Landeskenner für Deutschland. Dann hat man in der Regel eine Zahl und dann kann man sich noch einen zwei- bis dreistelligen Kürzel hinten dran setzen.
Das ist aber schon eine uralte Sache, also die Landeskenner, die wurden schon mit der ersten Funktagung vergeben. Also es war so im Jahre 1906, wo sich die ersten Länder zusammengerottet haben und festgestellt haben, dass Frequenzen endlich sind. Das heißt, wenn jemand auf einer Frequenz sendet, kann nicht jemand anderes auf derselben Frequenz senden. Da hat man ja gerade auch so mit mehr Leistung, dass man drüber kommt. Und die haben sich dann schon überlegt, wofür brauchen wir denn jetzt überhaupt Funk? Erstmal halt generell so für Radio, für Kommunikation. Man wollte ja immer den Atlantik überqueren, für Kommunikation halt zwischen dem Europa und den neuen Staaten da drüben. Und da hat man halt einfach ein paar Sachen festgelegt, dass zum Beispiel auch Schiffe Funk kriegen. Die sollen auf bestimmte Frequenzen halt arbeiten. Und damit man halt erkennen kann, von wo die Station kommt, wurden diese sogenannten Landescanner eingeführt, die auch lustigerweise nicht nur im Amateurfunk, sondern auch im Schiffsfunk und auch im Flugfunk dieselben Präfixe haben, also mit denselben Buchstaben anfangen. Deutschland hat man ja gerade schon gehabt, dass das dann halt irgendwie mit einem D anfängt, in bestimmten Bereichen. Nicht die komplette D-Spanne, aber ein Teil davon. Jetzt Frankreich, hatte Fabienne vorhin genannt, fängt mit einem F an. Foxtrot, USA.
Die Schweiz zum Beispiel mit HB.
Hohe Berge.
Sicher. Ein Funkzeichen, das bekommt man dann, also man darf es jetzt irgendwie im Rahmen selber aussuchen, aber man kommt verliehen oder man darf es offiziell benutzen, nachdem man eine Prüfung hat oder was?
Man darf es bezahlen, wenn man eine Prüfung hat.
Zumindest in Deutschland genauso. Und die Funkzeichen, die werden in Deutschland auch von der Bundesnetzagentur vergeben, die generell für diesen Bereich zuständig ist. Also man macht erst mal eine Prüfung bei der Bundesnetzagentur, damit darf man theoretisch... Ja, natürlich, man lernt vorher einiges.
Und vielleicht macht man sogar vorher noch einen Kurs.
Noch mal ganz von Anfang an, also was überhaupt unterliegt einer Regelung? Also wir sagen, ich erhalte anscheinend eine Erlaubnis, um irgendwas zu tun. Was genau ist diese Erlaubnis? Ist es die Erlaubnis, ein Gerät zu benutzen?
Es ist die Erlaubnis zu frickeln, tatsächlich. Also ich darf selbst dann Geräte bauen, ich darf Antennen bauen, ich darf diese benutzen, ohne jetzt irgendwie so ein Gütesiegel da drauf zu haben. Jedes andere Gerät, was irgendwie funkt, was in deinen Finger kriegst, die haben irgendein Zeichen hinten drauf, dass die geprüft worden sind und dass die für okay befunden worden sind. Ob es ein Walkie Talkie ist, ob es ein Babyphone ist, ob es irgendwie dein Gerät ist, mit dem du deine Lichter ein- und ausschaltest, ohne von der Couch aufzustehen. Die haben alle ein Siegel drauf, dass die für okay befunden worden sind.
Als Funkamateur. Das heißt aber auch, wenn ich sozusagen mit Amateurfunk, Funkamateuren will, kann ich mir einfach sozusagen ein Gerät kaufen, was diese Frequenzen und Technologie kann und kann dann mit denen reden.
Theoretisch kannst du mitreden, ist aber... Eine Artungswidrigkeit. Weil du hast keinen Lizenz gemacht dafür. Also du weißt nicht, was du da machst.
Aber du hast doch gerade gesagt, es geht um das Gütesiegel auf dem Gerät.
Naja, ne, stopp. Also es gibt diese sogenannten PMR-Geräte. Das sind Geräte, die du im Baumarkt kaufen kannst. Die sind auf bestimmten Frequenzen festgenagelt. Da kannst du für 5 Frequenzen auswählen. Es gibt die CB-Funkgeräte, die kannst du kaufen und dann kannst du sie benutzen. Wenn wir jetzt allerdings von einem Amateurfunkdienst, von einem Funkamateur reden, dann sind das bestimmte Frequenzen, die in den Wandplänen festgelegt sind. Das sind wesentlich mehr Frequenzen, als die anderen Geräte können.
Das heißt also Geräte, mit denen man diese Frequenzen alle nutzen kann, die haben nie so einen Gütesiegel?
Na die können auch eins haben. Allerdings normalerweise verfällt das halt, wenn du das Gerät aufmachst.
Muss ich ja nicht.
Na aber wir dürfen. Und wir dürfen es umbauen.
Nee, darum geht es jetzt nicht, sondern meine Frage ist jetzt, kann ich ein Gerät kaufen, das so einen Gütesiegel trägt, mit dem ich sozusagen auf diese ganzen Frequenzbande als Amateurfunk zugreifen kann?
Du kannst zuhören.
Na hören darfst du. Also hören darfst du immer.
Na und senden. Ich mache das Gerät nicht auf.
Also gibt es ein Gerät? Genau, senden darfst du nicht. Und der Hintergrund ist der, die Frequenz, also das Gerät, was hier vor uns steht zum Beispiel, das kann ich wild umstellen auf verschiedene Frequenzen, zum Beispiel auch auf den Schiffsfunk. Und dann würde ich ja den Schiffsfunk stören. Oder ich kann Taxifunk stören oder ich kann alles mögliche stören.
Aber nochmal gefragt, also ich kaufe dieses Gerät, das Gerät hat möglicherweise so einen Siegel, ich darf es aber nicht sendend benutzen. Richtig.
Also du nicht.
Du darfst aber zum Beispiel ein CB-Funk Gerät zulegen, was auch eben, das ist der große Unterschied eben zum Amateurfunk, der CB-Funk, da dürfen zum Beispiel nur geprüfte und zugelassene Geräte eben verwendet werden. Gleichzeitig darf man zum Beispiel nicht irgendwie mit seinem Amateurfunk-Equipment in den CB-Funk-Bereich, eben weil man keine, naja, kein zugelassenes Gerät hat.
Weil da kein Siegel drauf ist und weil die Sendeleistung nicht begrenzt ist, weil wir alle CB-Funker wegdrücken würden in der Umgebung, die das nicht mehr benutzen können und man die CB-Funker schützen möchte vor diesen bösen Amateurfunkern. Was ich gut verstehen kann, die sollen halt diese Frequenzen auch für sich wirklich haben und nutzen dürfen.
Okay, so. Ich erlange also, was auch immer abschließt, die Erlaubnis in bestimmten Frequenzbändern zu senden.
Na, erstmal, mit der Prüfung wird nur gesagt, dass du das Fachwissen hast und zwar sowohl das Technische als auch das Betriebstechnik, also wie mache ich das, als auch die gesetzlichen Grundlagen alle kennst, sprich welche Einschränkungen gibt es.
Ich will nicht mehr Amateurfunk.
Wenn du diese Prüfung gemacht hast, und da gibt es zwei in Deutschland, A und E, wenn du die gemacht hast, dann kannst du die Zulassung zum Amateurfunkdienst beantragen und da teilst du mit welches Rufzeichen du haben möchtest.
Wie viele 1000 Euro kostet das?
70.
Na die Prüfung selbst kostet 80 Euro für die Klasse E und für die Klasse A 110 Euro und das Rufzeichen kostet nochmal 70 Euro, also bist du zwischen 150 und 180 Euro dabei.
Was ist Klasse A und Klasse E?
Ah, E kann man für Einsteiger nennen und für A ist dann Advanced quasi.
Wir nennen sie auch die Lizenz zum Löten. Also mit A darf man tatsächlich auch Funkgeräte bauen und darf auf alle Frequenzen drauf.
Das darf ich mit E auch, nur mit E ist halt eine Einschränkung, dass ich nicht alle Frequenzen nutzen darf, nur begrenzte Ausgangsleistung. Früher war es zum Beispiel noch eingeschränkt, dass ich noch nicht mal ins Relaisfunkstellen benutzen durfte, sondern nur so Walkie-Talkie mäßig zwischen zwei Funkgeräten arbeiten durfte.
Ich habe direkt A gemacht, weil ich mir gesagt habe, wenn ich jetzt anfange zu lernen und erst die E mache, ist jetzt gar nicht garantiert, nie wieder hin und lernen.
Der Unterschied in der Prüfung ist einfach darin, dass die Technik sich unterscheidet. Also Betriebstechnik und Vorschriften sind bei beiden Prüfungen gleich und die Technik ist bei der Klasse A noch mal dreimal so großer Umfang.
Die Prüfungen bestehen aus drei Teilen, das sind die Fragebögen, multiple choice, da gibt es eben die Betriebstechnik, da lerne ich eben, wie mache ich das praktisch, wenn ich funke, wie rede ich mit Leuten, was ist ein QSO, dann gibt es den Technikteil, da gibt es dann darum, wie baue ich ein Funkgerät, was ist ein Spannungsgestellteoscillator, wie baue ich Milchstufen, wie berechne ich das alles, wie berechne ich Antennen, wie berechne ich den Sicherheitsabstand zu Antennen, berate, wenn er da drunter steht und dann gibt es noch die Vorschriften, wo dann drin steht, auf welchen Frequenzen darf ich tatsächlich senden, mit welcher Leistung.
Wie lange muss man dafür lernen, A, um sich das drauf zu schaffen und B, um das auszuwählen?
Das kommt drauf an, es sind 1780 Fragen, glaube ich, so um den Dreh oder 1700 oder so, für A.
Aus denen ausgewählt wird?
Aus denen wird ausgewählt, das sind dann drei Stunden Prüfung, die man hat. Und wenn man vor einem Kurs gemacht hat und irgendwie Grundwissen hat in der E-Technik, dann kann man das auch in drei Tagen lernen. Aber ich empfehle es deutlich, das nicht zu tun.
Also ich habe drei Monate gelernt, ungefähr.
Also ich habe die Klasse E über Nacht gelernt und ohne Kurs. Ich hatte das technische Grundwissen. Und die Klasse A, die hat mich dann aber doch nochmal irgendwie so einen Monat S-Bahnfahrt morgens gekostet, quasi.
Also es gibt da sehr coole Software zu, die an das Lernen sehr, sehr stark vereinfacht. Ich glaube, Affo Trainer heißt das Ding mittlerweile. Was man mit WINE auch unter Linux nutzen kann übrigens. Und das stellt halt damit diese ganzen Fragen vor und man wird dann abgefragt, das hat dann auch irgendwie Statistik drin und fragt immer wieder die, die man nicht konnte und so weiter.
Es hat Hilfestellungen drin, es verlinkt automatisch auf eine Seite, wo man das Ganze nochmal in einer Kurzform erklärt bekommt und es ist echt gut, das zu tun.
Okay, jetzt habe ich ja gelernt, Amateurfunk heißt im Englischen Ham Radio. Fabienne, ist bei euch die Prüfung auch so kompliziert und langwierig oder ist das ihr so wie eine Pistole kaufen?
Wir haben drei Niveaus, wir haben Technician, das ist so der Einsteiger, wir haben General, das ist der mittlere und dann haben wir Extra und die ersten zwei sind ziemlich einfach. Ich würde sagen, die ersten zwei passen in die erste Einsteiger von der Deutschen und die Extra ist ein bisschen leichter als die so advanced von Deutschland. Weil, ich sage das, weil eine Freundin von uns, die ist Deutschen und die hat das in Deutschland gemacht und dann ist die in den USA angekommen und man durfte in den USA aus Ausländer auch die amerikanische Prüfung machen. Es kostet bei uns 15 Dollar total, wenn man alle drei in einen Tag macht, dann kostet das nur 15 Dollar, das kostet so 15 Dollar pro Prüfung und wenn du alle drei Prüfungen in einen Tag machst, dann kostet das nur 15 Dollar und es gibt auch Prüfungen, die kostenlos sind und ich mache die, ich bin so dabei als die Prüfer, weil wir haben andere Systeme in den USA, wir haben so, ja, wir können so selbst eine Club, so eine Gruppe machen, die so lizenziert ist, die Prüfungen zu machen und ich gehöre dazu jetzt seit ein paar Wochen jetzt eigentlich eine Prüfung, die kostenlos ist, aber das ist ein bisschen, das ist nicht überall in Amerika kostenlos, normalerweise kostet das von 10 Dollar und für die Deutsche und Deutschen ist die amerikanische Prüfung ziemlich einfach. Wenn du so, wenn du kurz so vor, also vor einem Monat die deutsche Prüfung gemacht hat und du hast das alles so frisch im Kopf, dann würdest du sehr schnell so die amerikanische Prüfung bekommen. Es gibt nur so ein paar amerikanische Regeln, die ein bisschen anders sind, aber es ist nicht so weit weg von der deutschen Prüfung.
Ja, man sagt ja auch, dass die amerikanische Prüfung für Amerikaner so schwierig ist, weil sie als E-Einheiten das metrische System lernen müssen dafür.
So jetzt hat Fabienne gerade erzählt, sie ist da, also die haben einen Club gegründet und da werden dann Prüfungen gemacht, da wird wahrscheinlich auch das Wissen vermittelt. Wie ist denn das, also ihr habt das hier im Club gemacht, wie ist das denn in Deutschland? Wenn ich jetzt Funkamateur werden will, wo gehe ich denn dahin? Also gibt es da Bildungsinstitutionen oder wie läuft das?
Es ist ganz unterschiedlich. Also die Prüfung kann ich in Deutschland nur bei der Bundesnetzagentur machen. Die hat so, ich glaube aktuell 10 Außenstellen, die Prüfungen abnehmen. Die machen dann so, ich sag mal, alle vier bis sechs Wochen eine Prüfung. Da passen im Prüfungsraum so zwischen 15 und 30 Leute rein. Hier in Berlin passen nur zum Beispiel 15 Leute rein. Also in Berlin kann man auch eine Prüfung machen. Man meldet sich vorher per Formular bei der Bundesnetzagentur, das ist halt eine deutsche Behörde, wie es üblich ist. Man kriegt dann irgendwann ein Antwortschreiben. Ja, wir haben dann noch einen freien Prüfungstermin am Dann und Dann, in irgendwann x Wochen oder x Monaten. Und überweisen sie jetzt schon mal die ganzen Gebühren dafür. Natürlich. Ja, und dann hast du einen Prüfungstermin, auf den du hinarbeiten kannst. Du kannst selbstständig lernen, du kannst mit Büchern lernen, du kannst online Kurse belegen, wo du jede Woche eine E-Mail kriegst, wo du die Antworten dann halt wieder zurückschickst und dann auch ausgewertet kriegst. Du kannst einen Amateurfunk-Kurs besuchen, der entweder halt von lokalen Amateurfunk-Clubs angeboten wird oder halt auch bei der Volkshochschule oder auch hier im CCC einfach. Wir machen das ja auch hier. Das ist vollkommen unterschiedlich, wie du lernen möchtest. Hauptsache, du lernst für die Prüfung und machst die Prüfung bei der Bundesnetzagentur.
Also quasi so eine Art Unisport.
Also an der TU Berlin zum Beispiel ist eine Amateurfunkgruppe, DK0TU heißen die. Das ist das Rufzeichen ihrer Clubstation. Und die bieten tatsächlich einen Amateurfunkkurs an, der sogar Leistungspunkte bekommt, die man in Studium einbringen kann in entsprechenden Fächern. Also Elektrotechnik zum Beispiel, da bietet sich das natürlich an.
Studenten aufgemerkt.
Und im Oktober geht da übrigens wieder ein neuer Kurs los. Und es gibt mehrere Universitäten, die auch Amateurfunkgruppen da haben. Ich weiß aber nicht, wie es da mit Kursen aussieht, die angerechnet werden können. Aber in Berlin haben wir das, dass es eben als Teil vom Elektrotechnikstudium anerkannt werden kann.
Und ist das so quasi, also wenn ich irgendwo in Deutschland lebe, ist die Chance relativ hoch, dass ich was finde, wo ich das auch kostenlos tatsächlich machen kann, weil das so ein Hobbyding ist? Oder kostet das auch Geld?
Kurse sind unterschiedlich. Also das ist dann immer von Gruppe zu Gruppe unterschiedlich. Ich biete jetzt hier die Kurse kostenlos an einfach, weil es mir Spaß macht und ich dann hinter mehr Leute habe, mit denen ich auch funken kann. Das ist mein großer Spaß da dran und das hat sich jetzt hier in Berlin schon ausgezahlt tatsächlich. Es gibt aber andere Gruppen, die sagen, was nix kostet, kann auch nix sein, die nehmen dann halt eine Gebühr dafür oder dass sie sagen, du musst Mitglied in einem Funkamateur Club werden, damit das sich auch mal ein bisschen rechnet einfach. Es ist vollkommen unterschiedlich, aber meistens ist das gar nicht mal so teuer. Also wenn ich vergleichen würde, ich würde so einen Kurs irgendwo in einer freien Wirtschaft irgendwie belegen, da kannst du mal tausende von Euro hinlegen. Hier kannst du halt quasi grundlang Elektrotechnik und Funktechnik, HF Technik einfach mal lernen. Muss natürlich dann nebenbei auch die Gesetzeskunde und die Betriebstechnik noch lernen und die Prüfung machen, aber das ist relativ günstig dann. Wir haben das jetzt hier so gemacht, genau richtig, das waren 22 Wochen mit jeweils zweieinhalb Stunden für die Klasse A darauf hinzuarbeiten. Das ist auch ungefähr der Rahmen, der angesetzt werden sollte, wenn du einen Kurs besuchst. Es gibt Intensivkurse, es gibt auch Kurse, die ein ganzes Jahr einfach überlaufen, die halt auch online dann sind oder so. Es ist ganz unterschiedlich, wie der Kurs halt aufgebaut ist.
Und ist das sozusagen dieser Kurs, den du hier gemacht hast, ein halbes Jahr lang, ist das dann, man kommt einmal die Woche diesen Abend her und damit ist gut, dann muss man dann noch zu Hause irgendwie stundenlang sitzen und löten und lernen und Dinge tun.
Also lernen solltest du auf jeden Fall danach noch. Also du solltest auf jeden Fall danach noch, je nachdem wie natürlich dein Vorwissen ist, aber du solltest auf jeden Fall mal noch so zwei, drei Monate einplanen, um wirklich immer sich regelmäßig dann hinzusetzen abends und...
Jeden Abend?
Ja, nicht jeden Abend, aber schon so alle zwei Tage und gegen Ende natürlich, wenn es auf die Prüfung zugeht, am besten schon jeden Abend und einfach mal halt entweder Prüfungsaufgaben durchrechnen oder einfach mal in der S-Bahn sitzen und auf dem Telefon so da diese Betriebsfragen, dafür eignet sich das total gut, Betrieb oder Rechtsfragen, einfach mal durchklicken.
Es ist tatsächlich sehr unterschiedlich, wie die Vorkenntnisse sind. Also ich habe halt vor einiger Zeit mal mit dem Elektrotechnikstudium angefangen, da dann zwar die Hälfte vergessen, aber durch den Kurs. Montags ist das alles wieder aufgefrischt worden, dann ein bisschen zwischendurch üben und naja, dann kann es halt auch reichen, dass man am Mittwoch anfängt, wenn am Montag die Prüfung ist. Aber das ist halt wirklich Stress und dann macht man 20 Stunden am Stück die Prüfungsfragen, also wirklich am Stück 20 Stunden. Wenn man das kann, kann man das auch so machen, aber das ist wirklich nicht zu empfehlen.
Nee, ein bisschen Spaß sollte ja auf jeden Fall schon dabei bleiben.
Also man muss tatsächlich so ein bisschen Aufwand investieren, das habe ich jetzt vernommen. Dann macht man diese Prüfung und wenn man die bestanden hat, dann kann man sein Funkzeichen, Funku, wie heißt das? Rufzeichen. Rufzeichen beantragen quasi. Also man sucht sich eins aus innerhalb dieses Rahms und sagt dann hier, ich hätte das gern, zahlt das Geld und dann hat man das.
Wenn es noch frei war und nicht reserviert ist, weil da gerade jemand gestorben ist oder so, dann ja.
Auch ein interessantes Wortmotiv. Ah, andere Geschichte. Gut, dann wissen wir jetzt, wie man zu einem Rufzeichen kommt und wir werden dann gleich mal darüber sprechen, was man damit so genau anstellen kann. Vor allem noch ein kleines bisschen Musik. Und hier behandelte es sich, glaube ich, um einen höheren Wunsch und zwar Retribution von Pacific. Rechibusion von Pacific, ein altes Amiga 500 Demo, das der Danimo ausgesucht hat, der hier beim Chaosradio 224 und auch bei vielen anderen Chaosradios sich ganz herzzerreißend großartig um die Technik kümmert und nicht nur das, auch noch die Nerd News heraus sucht, die präsentiert werden von Christina.
Die Bundesregierung plant nach Recherchen von NDR, WDR und Süddeutscher Zeitung die Einrichtung einer neuen Bundesbehörde namens CITES. Sie soll für Bundespolizei, BKA und Verfassungsschutz Nachrichten von Diensten wie WhatsApp, Signal und REMA einschlüsseln. Dabei dürfte es jedoch nur nachrangig um Versuche gehen, die Verschlüsselungsmechanismen zu knacken. Vielmehr werden Nachrichten per Bundestrojaner der sogenannten Quellen-TKÜ vor der Verschlüsselung abgefangen. Angeblich soll die neue Behörde aber keine neuen Befugtes erhalten. Der ehemalige Datenschutzbeauftragte Peter Schaer merkt jedoch an, dass die Strafprozessordnung keine Rechtsgrundlage und damit keine Legitimation für den Einsatz von Staatstrojanern für Online-Durchsuchungen enthalten. CITES soll mit 60 Mitarbeitern starten und bis 2022 auf 400 Mitarbeiter anwachsen. Parallel dazu sollen die Mittel zur Entschlüsselung solcher Nachrichten beim BND, der nicht an CITES teilnehmen soll, ebenfalls erheblich aufgestockt werden. Das Kabinett der Bundesregierung hat unterdessen einen Gesetzesentwurf befürwortet, der dem Bundesnachrichtendienst nach NSA-Manier das Abschnorcheln von Internetverkehr auch in Deutschland gestattet. Dieses würde im Nachhinein die vom NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss kritisierten Praktiken des BND legitimieren, bei dem der Dienst Daten zum Beispiel an Knoten wie dem Dezix in Frankfurt abgreift. Bislang definierte der BND den Standort des Dezix schlicht als virtuelles Ausland. Ein mehr als fragwürdiges Vorgehen. Der BND brauche diese Befugnisse, um Ausländer im Inland abhören zu können, die mit dem Ausland kommunizieren. So begründet auch die NSA ihr Vorgehen im US-Inland. Wie der BND dabei sicherstellen will, dass wie vorgeschrieben keine Kommunikation zwischen Deutschen im In- oder Ausland abgehört werden, bleibt unterdessen sein Geheimnis. Der NSA ist diese saubere Trennung jedenfalls nicht gelungen. In jedem Fall darf sich der Steuerzahler auf mehr Kosten von jährlich mindestens 6, 5 Millionen Euro freuen. Die Direktorenkonferenz der Landesmedienanstalten ist sich einig, dass das Analogfernsehen in den Kabelnetzen zügig abgeschaltet werden soll. Derzeit schauen noch rund 24% aller Zuschauer analog Fernsehen per Kabelanschluss. Der Verband der Kabelnetzbetreiber plant die Komplettabschaltung der Analog-TV-Verbreitung bis 2018. Dann sollen weniger als 20% der Zuschauer noch den alten Empfangsweg nutzen. Bei Unity Media ist bereits Mitte 2017 Schluss. Die analogen Fernsehsignale im Kabelnetz belegen im Vergleich zu den gut komprimierbaren Digitalsendern sehr viel Bandbreite auf dem Koaxialkabel, das auf der letzten Meile gemeinsam genutzt wird. Diese Bandbreite fehlt dann für die Verbreitung von HDTV oder Breitband-Internet.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück im Chaosradio 224, wo wir über Amateurfunk reden und zwar mit Fabienne, Lars, Mutax und Matthias. Hallo und willkommen zurück.
Hallo.
Und weil es den Nerdnews ja gerade auch so ein bisschen um Datenschutz ging oder beziehungsweise um die Dinge, die passieren, damit wir nicht so viel Datenschutz haben, darüber wolltet ihr an dieser Stelle auch ein bisschen reden.
Ich denke, das passt einfach super rein. Bei Amateurfunk ist das total einfach. Es gibt keinen Datenschutz. Es ist offene Sprache, was wir dort haben, so heißt es tatsächlich. So steht es auch in den Regulations drin, die weltweit gelten. Es darf nur auf eine Sprache verwendet werden. Das heißt, alles, was ich spreche, muss offen sein. Es darf nicht verschlüsselt sein.
Also Esperanto und Latein.
Das steht zum Beispiel in österreichischen Regeln in Gesetzgebung noch mal explizit drin.
In den Statuten steht, dass die Art und Weise, wie man kommuniziert über Funk, soll für alle, die da theoretisch zuhören, auch verständlich sein.
Richtig.
Das heißt, wenn ich in Deutschland funke, soll ich Deutsch sprechen? Oder wie ist das gemeint?
Ich glaube, da steht offene Sprache und etwas, das halt gängig ist. Also nicht verschlüsselt, nicht mit Kotwörtern. Man darf zum Beispiel auch nur Nachrichten.
Wie war nochmal euer Rufzeit?
Moment. Was ist dein Kurs?
Ja gut, aber das ist ja Amateurfunktion. Das ist ja wiederum offene Sprache. Das ist ja gängig.
Was du heute auch nicht machen darfst, ist Nachrichten für Dritte übermitteln. Das heißt, du darfst zum Beispiel keinen Telegram oder Choreodienst damit betreiben, dass du über Amateurfunk, über die Frequenzen und mit der Technik, mit deinem Rufzeichen Nachrichten für Dritte übermittelst, weil das eine Teilnahme am Amateurfunkdienst wäre und die anderen müssen eben auch ein Rufzeichen dafür haben. Und man kann sich das so ein bisschen vielleicht erklären mit Funken, wie das so früher war, wo das herkommt. Das waren halt so Agentensachen, die da abgelaufen sind. Du möchtest halt, wenn du eine Funkaussendung aufnimmst, möchtest du wissen, ob das jetzt irgendwie möglicherweise Spione sind, die geheime Informationen aus deinem Land nach draußen senden. Und wenn das alles offene Sprache ist und nicht verschlüsselt und das Rufzeichen genannt wird, dann weißt du ja, wer das ist.
Warte mal, mir geht gerade eine Laterne auf. Kommt das daher, dieses alberne, der Adler ist gelandet? Ist das daher sozusagen, dass Agenten über Funk kommuniziert haben?
Das wäre zum Beispiel verschlüsselte Kommunikation, weil niemand weiß, was das bedeutet.
Na doch, der Adler ist gelandet, also ich meine es ja.
Richtig.
Nein, aber ernsthaft, kommt das daher? Also kommt das Memen der Agenten-Sprache daher?
Ich persönlich leite es mir halt genau daher.
Das ist natürlich nur für die bekannt, die auch wissen, was dahinter steht. Einfach, wenn das vorher halt ausgetauscht wurde, was das Codewort bedeutet, dann kann das auch verwendet werden. Aber für alle, die außen stehen, die wissen natürlich nicht, was es bedeutet.
Aber jetzt mal ganz ernsthaft, das steht in der Statuten. Und jetzt funk ich aber mit meiner Agentenkollegin und sah, der Adler ist gelandet.
Was passiert denn dann? Na im Worst Case steht dann dein Pallwagen von der Bundesnetzagentur von deiner Haustür. Du hast dich einer Ordnungswilligkeit schuldig gemacht. Also die fahren tatsächlich rum und dann musst du halt dafür Geld bezahlen.
Das ist eine Ordnungswilligkeit. Dafür, dass ich ornithologische Dinge ausgetauscht habe?
Na ja, wenn du es im Rahmen deiner Amateurfunk-Geschichten gemacht hast, wird dir eventuell die Zulassung entzogen, sprich das Rufzeichen. Und du hast da das Ordnungswilligkeitsverfahren am Hals. Das kann dir durchaus passieren. Das kommt auch vor. Also wir hatten, ich glaube Herr Liemerl hast auch den Fall tatsächlich, wo eben jemand seinen Angestellten über Amateurfunk Informationen zu seinen Kunden gegeben hat, die er anfahren soll, wo er vorbeifahren soll im Außendienst. Und denen ist dann beides das Rufzeichen entzogen worden.
Weil?
Weil das eine kommerzielle Nutzung des Amateurfunkdienstes war.
Okay, ne, aber das meine ich nicht. Ich meine, wir sind ja hier im Chaos Computer Club und es hat da noch keine Technologie gegeben, wo nicht versucht wurde, das vielleicht noch ein bisschen umzubiegen. Und ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass es auch das Bedürfnis gibt, da mal zu sagen, wie breit können wir denn diese Grenze ziehen? Und wenn man sich jetzt so eine quasi Steganografiesprache ausdenkt...
Deswegen machen wir das auch nicht.
Ist das dann einfach Amateurfunk, da weißt du das von vornherein?
Ich bin ein bisschen erschüttert.
Ja, spannend wird das Ganze dann bei Packet Radio. Und wenn man zum Beispiel Internetprotokolle über Amateurfunk dann spricht.
Aber ich wollte kurz nochmal zurückdrehen zu dem Punkt, wo du vorhin gefragt hast, über was wir uns im Amateurfunk unterhalten. Es ist ja nur Belangloses. Also ganz oft sind die Gespräche darüber, wie jetzt gerade das Funkwetter ist, was ich für ein Funkgerät aufgebaut habe, was für ein Antenne ich aufgebaut habe, wie es meiner Familie geht und so weiter und so fort. Was zum Beispiel auch Themen nicht sind, wäre Politik. Das gehört so ein bisschen dazu zum Hemmspirit. Natürlich gibt es Leute, die sich darüber unterhalten, aber Politik ist halt einfach ein Thema, da hast du immer Streit. Das möchte man nicht unbedingt. Genauso Religion. Wenn wir jetzt auf Extreme treiben. Interessant war einfach mal ein kurzes Gespräch, was ich mit irgendeinem Scheich in Saudi-Arabien geführt habe. Also mit dem möchte ich nicht unbedingt über Politik und Religion sprechen. Da bin ich froh, dass ich nur eine Funkverbindung aufgebaut habe. Und freue mich einfach darüber, mal mit so jemand gesprochen zu haben, was halt einfach Völkerverständigung ist.
Ich bin mir da momentan nicht ganz sicher, weil es klingt wie so eine Mischung aus einerseits Völkerverständigung, aber andererseits so ein sehr keimfreier Kindergarten.
Interessante Analogie, so habe ich es noch nicht gesehen. Mir geht es ja beim Amateurfunk mehr um das Basteln und das Ausprobieren und Technik halt auch zu entwickeln, zu nutzen. Es muss ja nicht unbedingt Sprache sein, das kann ja auch digitaler Funk sein, also mit dem Computer hinten dran. Das kann auch Morsen sein. Morsen können natürlich nur die verstehen, die auch morsen, aber es ist auf eine Sprache.
Okay, also per Statut?
Natürlich, klar, sicher. Du musstest natürlich dafür lernen, genauso wie halt die Protokolle, mit denen ich digitale Daten übertrage.
Den Punkt hatten wir noch gar nicht. Ich bin immer davon ausgegangen, wenn wir Amateurfunk, dann ist das menschliche Sprache, die wir übertragen. Das ist scheinbar nicht der Fall.
Das Einfachste ist ja CW, also Morrison. Da hast du Ton, lang, Ton, kurz oder kein Ton. Und das ist halt binär, im Prinzip, oder trinär. Und das ist ja auch schon ein digitaler Modus quasi. Und das kannst du halt weitertreiben, indem du mit einem Rechner abwechselnde Frequenzen sendest und das auswertest.
Ist das erlaubt?
Und das ist erlaubt, weil die Protokolle, weil die Protokolle, mit denen man das macht, die sind öffentlich. Und es gibt halt eine Handvoll von Digimodes. Die sind alle dokumentiert und standardisiert. Dokumentiert auf jeden Fall, kann man nachlesen, wie die gehen. Und die darf man dann benutzen, solange man jetzt nicht anfängt, darüber verschlüsselt Daten auszutauschen. Das tut man wieder nicht.
Sorry, es fängt bei ganz alten Modis an wie Faxe. Das heißt, du kannst etwas einscannen und du hast dann hell und dunkel. Das kannst du natürlich als nicht senden und senden übertragen. Und das kannst du auch auf der anderen Seite wieder dekodieren. Das ist offen, das ist halt simpel. Dann geht es weiter mit Funk-Fernschreiber. Fernschreiber kennst du vielleicht noch, wo früher so ein Telex drüber weggeschickt wurde. Das ging über Drahtleitungen, das kannst du aber genauso über Funk machen. Die kannst du an ein Funkgerät anschließen, dann kannst du genauso die Signale übertragen. Die haben halt einfach auch ein Zweit-Ton-System, die du-du-du-düt irgendwie und kommt auf der anderen Seite dann auch wieder so an. Das kannst du auch entschlüsseln.
Sollen wir sie quälen?
Und dann geht es jetzt weiter mit Modis, die einfach mal, nee, mach ich jetzt nicht SSTV an. Du kannst Bilder übertragen, das geht auch. Und du kannst auch Fernsehen übertragen. Es sind ganz viele Modis von Funk-Amateuren entwickelt worden, womit mehr Daten zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt übertragen werden können. Das heißt, dass ich eins von zum Beispiel 4.096 Bits zu einem Zeitpunkt übertragen kann. Und das kann eins von 4.096 unterschiedlichen Bits sein. Das wurde im Amateurfunk entwickelt und wird heute bei solchen tollen Techniken wie VDSL eingesetzt.
Okay, aber wird das jetzt auch irgendwie benutzt? Also macht man damit was? Was denn?
Ja, Daten übertragen, das ist dann wie chatten. Also das ist tatsächlich so, du sitzt am Richter und tippst dann halt einfach rein, von wem irgendwie ein Rufzeichen kommt oder wer du bist. Und dann kannst du dich auch damit austauschen. Du kannst einfach Daten hin und her schicken. Im Grunde auch genauso halt, wie ich in Sprache dann irgendwie Gespräch führe. Ganz häufig sieht man da auch solche Sachen da drin, wie es gerade halt dem Hund geht und so weiter und so fort.
Ich mache sowas mal an und halte dann gleich den Lautsprecher wieder zu. Das ist ein Bild meiner Katze. Jetzt halte ich den Lautsprecher zu, sonst werden wir wahnsinnig.
Sehr schön. Viel Spaß mit Mutagskatze. Ihr habt noch in der Vorbereitung eine Liste mit Dingen gegeben, die man machen kann als Amateurfunk oder die man halt damit betreibt. Das heißt, du kannst das nicht abbrechen, ein Katzenbild?
Nein, diese Android-App kann man nicht abbrechen, wenn man es einmal gestartet hat. Das dauert jetzt eine Minute.
Das klingt ja großartig.
Aber in einer Minute könnt ihr die Katze von Mutag sehen. Das ist total toll. Wenn sie lila wäre, würde es auch noch schönere Töne geben.
Ich glaube, rausfiltern kann das hier hoffentlich niemand mehr.
Nun, wie gesagt, es gibt Dinge, die man tun kann mit Amateurfunk. Ihr habt mir so eine kleine Liste gegeben. Wir gehen jetzt mal durch, was man noch so machen kann. Da gibt es zum Beispiel einen QRP.
Ja, das ist wieder so eine sogenannte Q-Gruppe. Diese Q-Gruppen sind in sogenannten Radio Regulations beschrieben. Das ist diese weltweite Regulation, wie Funk generell abgewickelt werden soll. Nicht nur Amateurfunk, sondern auch der Flugfunk und der Seefunk. Und diese Q-Gruppen sind Abkürzungen für irgendwelche Sachen. QRP ist sogar recht gut zu merken. Q fängt irgendwie alles Mögliche an, weil Q selten in der Sprache verwendet wird. Und RP steht für Reduce Power. Das heißt, dass ich mit so wenig Leistung wie möglich so weit wie möglich komme.
Vielleicht noch ganz kurz, wo die Q-Gruppen benutzt wurden. Bei Morsen. Ich möchte bei Morsen mit möglichst wenig Zeichen möglichst viel Information übertragen an die Gegenstelle. Deswegen hat man sich diese Abkürzung ausgedacht. Und das Q hört man eben gut raus. Und hat danach immer noch zwei Buchstaben, meistens drei buchstabig. Man kann darüber eben relativ komplexe Sachen übermitteln, wie ich habe bei dir Hintergrundgeräusche, ich kann dich nicht so gut hören oder bei dir sind irgendwelche, geh doch mit der Leistung mal hoch, geh mit der Leistung mal runter. Das kann man über drei Buchstaben mitteilen. Und QAP ist eben auch eine von vielen Abkürzungen. Genauso QSO. Und im Flugfunk gibt es eben auch so was wie, was war das, Notwassern oder wir müssen jetzt die Antenne ablassen oder irgendwie so komische Sachen.
Alles mögliche gehen sich ja weg und so was. Das kann man zum Beispiel einen Hubschrauber mal schicken, die hier irgendwie in der Gegend rumfliegen. Aber die Q-Gruppen sind ganz praktisch halt einfach auch. Man kann Kommunikation betreiben, auch wenn man nicht die selbe Sprache spricht. Also stell dir vor, vor dir steht ein Japaner und du sprichst kein Japanisch und der Japaner spricht kein Deutsch. Kannst du dich über Q-Gruppen mit ihm unterhalten? Das geht.
Gehen sie weg. Fahren sie die Antenne ein. Na gut. Also QRP, ich setze mich sozusagen hin und schalte den Leistungsregel auf ganz gering und versuche dann, wie weit ich damit komme.
Naja, oder hast du eben ein selbstgebautes Gerät, mit dem man morsen kann? Also morsen ist halt Tonsenden oder kein Tonsenden. Ein einfaches Funkgerät kann man nicht bauen, weil du einfach nur eine ausschaltest und damit sitzt du mit einer kleinen Batterie halt irgendwo im Park mit einem Stück Draht dran und kannst damit um die ganze Welt funken.
Und dann schicke ich wieder eine Postkarte und kriege Gewinner einen Contest oder warum mache ich das?
Ja, so kann man es durchaus machen.
Okay, dann ist hier ein Echo Link. Was ist ein Echo Link?
Echo Link, wir hatten vorhin über die Repeater gesprochen, die etwas erhöht stehen und mit denen ich dann weiter…
Ein Repeater ist ein Relay.
Genau. Und diese Geräte können auch ans Internet angeschlossen sein und darüber kann ich dann meine Sprache zu einem anderen Repeater schicken, wo das dann wieder rausgesendet wird. Das heißt, ich mache diesen Repeater auf, sende eine schöne kleine DTMF-Tonfolge, das kennen wir ja alle irgendwie, wenn wir so auf dem Telefon rumklicken. Genau, da gab es dann komische Töne quasi. Und mit diesen Tönen kann ich dann einen anderen Repeater, wenn ich die Nummer kenne, anrufen. Und auf der anderen Seite kommt es raus, das ist dann auch weltweit verbunden über das Internet. Das Lustige ist einfach, ich kann dann halt mit meinem kleinen Handfunkgerät, was eigentlich nicht so viel Leistung hat und auch nicht die gute Antenne, um extra weite Strecken zu überbrücken, kann ich halt mich auf den nächsten Repeater einwählen und kann zum Beispiel nach Seattle rufen und dort mit Fabienne dann sprechen.
Und haben wir das tatsächlich gemacht.
Das haben wir tatsächlich schon gemacht, ja.
Fabienne, du hast ja vorhin erzählt, dass du häufiger auch mal mit Europa sprichst. Machst du das dann über diese Echo-Links oder versuchst du das dann erst mal terrestrisch hinzubekommen?
Nee, ich habe vor so einem Monat oder so die 20, die 40 Meter Wellenlänge, haben sich geöffnet besser und deswegen habe ich so eine 20 Meter Antenne in meiner, so hinter meinem Haus in Seattle ausgebaut und habe ich ein bisschen damit gespielt. Aber früher mal hatte ich auch mit Lars gesprochen über Echo-Link durch meine Repeater, mein Relay da in Seattle. Wir haben so 11 Relays in der Gegend von Seattle auf Analog und wir haben noch drei Relays in DMR.
Das können wir auch beim Autofahren machen dann.
Und ihr dürft es beide, weil es das Gesetz euch erlaubt. Ich glaube, wenn ich heute eine Sache aus der Sendung mitnehme, dann ist es, Amateurfunk lohnt sich, weil man da während des Autofahrens an technischen Geräten Knöpfe drücken darf.
Nein, nur am Funkgerät. Abgesehen davon wäre es wahrscheinlich im Falle eines Unfalls eine Einzelfallentscheidung, ob du abgelenkt warst.
Nur kurz dazu, in Seattle, wir haben Orte und Inseln, die ganz in der Nähe von Seattle sind, aber sehr schlechte Handyempfang. Und das macht Sinn, dass man so mit Amateurfunk mit jemandem reden kann. Torsten war auf einer Insel und ich war in Seattle und der hat keine Basis im Handy mehr und könnte nicht sein Handy benutzen. Dann könnten wir so ein bisschen kurz reden, wenn wir so fragen, wenn kommst du zu Hause oder irgendwas Kleines zu sagen.
Es gibt da auch eine sehr praktische Anwendung, das ist dann der Bereich Notfunk im Amateurfunk, wo man tatsächlich sagt, wenn es Katastrophenfälle gibt, sind Funk-Amateure diejenigen, die, weil sie noch eine Solarzelle und einen Bleiakku unterm Schreibtisch haben, weltweit Informationen weitergeben können und auch Hilfsaktionen mit unterstützen können, indem sie Informationen weitergeben. Wo gibt es wie viele Verletzte, wie ist die Situation in dem Ort, in dem du gerade bist, damit man jemanden Rettungskräfte, Daten weitergeben kann.
Ist Amateurfunk tatsächlich soweit verbreitet, dass man sagen kann, in welches Gebiet der Welt man auch immer will, mit Amateurfunk eine gute Chance dahin zu kommen?
Das sollte eigentlich möglich sein, ja. Und es gibt auch tatsächlich Untergruppen, die speziell die Notfunkdienst trainieren und das üben und da auch versuchen, das aufrechtzuerhalten. Und wenn man sich guckt, es gibt bei der Bundesnetzagentur eine PDF-Datei, wo alle Funk-Amateure Deutschlands aufgezählt sind mit ihren Rufzeichen. Man kann die Datenmangel auch durchsuchen und du weißt glaube ich aus dem Kopf, wie viele das sind ungefähr?
Etwa 60.000 aktuell.
Und das ist nur Deutschland?
Ist das aber so eine erste Weltgeschichte? Also sozusagen nur hochentwickelte, gut verdiente Länder? Also weil alles, was ich jetzt vorhin euch gehört habe, war auch sozusagen USA, Neuseeland, also ein Schaich.
Es ist überall auf der Welt verbreitet Amateurfunk. Es gibt einzelne Länder, die das unterbinden, beispielsweise Nordkorea. Ne, in China tatsächlich recht viel sogar verbreitet. Ich weiß natürlich nicht, wie viel davon mitgehört wird. Wir wissen, da ist ja eh alles offen, kann ja alles mitgehört werden. Aber so einfach nur Verbindung austauschen ist nicht schädlich. Nur es läuft. Also ich habe auch schon ab und zu mit China geredet.
Aber in Nordkorea ist es ganz verboten?
In Nordkorea ist es aktuell ganz verboten. Mal schauen, was sich da so tut. Also da gibt es immer wieder mal Aktionen, die versuchen, das mal wieder zu öffnen.
Aber auch so DDR-Zeiten war es erlaubt. Also aus der DDR heraus durfte man auch als Funkamateur funken.
Wie ist das so mit Vietnam, Nigeria?
Recht gut sogar verbreitet. Also es ist ganz unterschiedlich, wie es da dann auch verwendet wird und wie viele dort tatsächlich sind. Aber es ist überall sonst möglich.
Ich glaube, es ist tatsächlich nur in zwei Ländern verboten. Und eins davon war Nordkorea. Das andere Land fällt mir gerade nicht ein.
Aber verboten ist die eine Sache, die andere Sache die Verbreitung. Das wird auch seitdem bald betrieben.
Es ist eben die Technik, die mit einer Solarzelle und einer kleinen Batterie machbar ist. Und deswegen gerade in den Ländern, wo natürlich wenig Infrastruktur ist, ist das noch nicht verbreitet. Klar.
Ich kann ja tatsächlich mit einem Draht oder graphilbestäubten Hühnerdarm irgendwie einfach eine Antenne aufbauen und das durch die Gegend schieben.
Das ist eine Kurzwellenantenne.
Lieber Hörer, ich möchte, dass ihr das Bild graphitbestäubter Hühnerdarm in eurem Kopf behaltet.
Ja, beliebt sind auch Schnürsenkel, also geht auch, sollte aber feucht sein.
Ich möchte jetzt nicht länger drüber nachdenken. Ich möchte tatsächlich über Hardware möchte ich auch nochmal reden, aber ich würde noch mal kurz auf den Punkt, also was man damit machen kann, zu sprechen kommen. Gibt es auch so wie Geocaching als Sport- oder Freizeitbeschäftigung, dass man irgendwas damit macht?
Es gibt Fuchsjagden zum Beispiel.
Ja, das Feld ist sehr breit, was der Amateurfunk bietet. Es gibt also verrückte tatsächlich, die dann auch sich Laufschuhe anziehen und so eine kleine Antenne mit Kopfhörern vor sich her tragen und versuchen dann halt einen sogenannten Peilsender zu finden, das heißt, es ist so ein Sender, der einfach nur irgendwelche Piepsöne von sich gibt und je nachdem wie du dich drehst, kommt das Signal stärker oder schlechter rein und dann weißt du auch ungefähr die Richtung, wo du hin musst.
Das kennen wir aus Computerspielen.
Ja, genau richtig. Dann rennen die so sieben Kilometer durch die Gegend irgendwie und klappern irgendwie vier, fünf Peilsender in der Zwischenzeit ab und versuchen als Erster halt auch ins Zielkrieg zu kommen damit.
Und besonders fies ist das, wenn der Sender sich bewegt, weil irgendjemand ihn vor sich ja trägt selber. Das gab es zum Beispiel während des Chaos Communication Camps. Das heißt dann Fuchsjagd. Da gab es eben so einen kleinen Sender, der ist so groß wie eine Streichholzschachtel ungefähr und der war halt irgendwo versteckt und der bewegte sich auch über das Camp. Dann musste man mit den Radio Badges das Ding finden und am Schluss war der halt irgendwie dann an dem Stand von den Münchnern, die die Radio Badges verteilt haben, versteckt.
Das war auch so absurd gewesen mit dem Radio Badge und der Antenne. Also man braucht dafür schon eine Richtantenne, das heißt so eine genannte Yagi-Antenne, die hat man vielleicht mal gesehen auf dem Hausdach. So früher Fernsehantennen, die dann halt so ein langer Stab mit Querstäben einfach drauf ist. Da gab es Leute, die haben auf dem Camp so eine Antenne aus metallenden Meta-Massbändern halt zusammengeschraubt und sind damit natürlich dagegen gerannt. Hat funktioniert und sah ziemlich cool aus.
Wo der ganze Zeit Camps hat, da habt ihr irgendwie auch mit der ISS, also mit der International Space Station.
Ja, also Satellitenfunk ist natürlich auch ein Teilbereich, den ich machen darf im Amateurfunk. Wir haben eigene Satelliten im Weltall, auch schon seit den 60er Jahren. Amateurfunk-Satelliten. Montagens sind es relativ wenige, nur so eine Handvoll. Es sollen aber wieder mehr werden. Über die darf ich dann kommunizieren. Das heißt, ich kann dann einmal hoch schicken, Signal. Dadurch, dass sie nicht geostationär sind, kommen die auch halt nur alle 90 Minuten mal vorbei und sind dann so für 15 Minuten zu hören. Und das Signal wird dann, wie bei einem Repeater, einfach verstärkt wieder runter gesendet und kann über eine größere Fläche empfangen werden. Das heißt, ich kann halt über einen Satelliten dann ohne Probleme einmal komplett Europa arbeiten.
Aber ihr habt die ISS gehört?
Ja, und die ISS hat auch so einen Repeater drauf und da sind ja auch noch Menschen oben drauf, so Kosmonauten, Astronauten, die auch in der Regel eine Funk-Amateurausbildung hinter sich haben und die haben da so als Freizeitbeschäftigung auch einen Dienstplan drin stehen, mal ab und zu mal Kommunikation zu betreiben, mit Amateurfunk, auch um noch mit den Menschen auf der Erde mal zu reden, quasi mit stinknormalen Leuten, also Funk-Amateuren quasi. Und dann kann es halt vorkommen, dass die dann abends einfach am Funkgerät sitzen und auch mal durch die Gegend rufen und du kannst mit denen dann auch reden.
Warte mal, warte mal, wenn ich eine Amateurfunkausbildung mache und ein Funkgerät habe, dann kann ich mit den Astronauten auf der ISS reden? Das sagt ihr mir jetzt nach anderthalb Stunden? Leute, das ist doch wichtig.
Wir müssen dich auch ein bisschen teasen.
Das ist ja echt großartig. Also hat einer von euch schon mal mit den Astronauten geredet?
Ich bin leider nicht durchgekommen, aber auf dem Camp haben wir, ich hatte da lustigerweise gerade vorher einen kurzen Vortrag gemacht, was ist Amateurfunk und hatte da so eh schon 20 Leute um mich herum und meinte so, ach so, wir können jetzt übrigens mal rausgehen. Es ist gerade irgendwie 22.40 Uhr, kommt die ISS vorbei geflogen. Da können wir mal gucken, ob wir funken können mit der und habe dann ein Funkgerät aufgebaut, so wie wir es jetzt auf dem Tisch stehen haben, so ein kleines Funkgerät einfach, habe eine Antenne genommen, die ich vor mir herhalten konnte und darauf richten konnte das Ganze. Also man kann sie auch mit so einem kleinen Handfunkgerät einfach schon empfangen, aber durchkomme ich da nicht. Ich brauchte schon ein bisschen gerichtete Verbindung dahin, aber ich brauche nicht viel Leistung, also kann ich auch mit 5 bis 10 Watt, also 5 Watt reichen sogar aus, so ISS, so komm ich hier nix im Weg, so und 400 Kilometer kann ich ja so überbrücken. Na ja und dann stand ich halt dort irgendwie und habe dann so den Arm ausgestreckt mit der Antenne dran und auf die ISS gehalten und auch immer schön nachgeführt. Nach 10 Minuten Schmerz ist auch schon im Arm, aber nun ja, das ist eine andere Geschichte. Und ich konnte den Kosmonauten halt hören, wie er gerade davon sprach, dass der Progressfrachter abgedockt hat, er jetzt auch wieder funken darf, weil wenn er dran hängt, darf er nicht funken und wenn er abgedockt ist und dann irgendwann verglüht ist, darf er auch wieder das Funkgerät einschalten, zumindest für Amateurfunk und wie er davon erzählte, dass er schon ein halbes Jahr oben ist, das war die Langzeitmission, also von den Kosmonauten, die ein ganzes Jahr da oben bleiben. Einer von denen war halt schon ein halbes Jahr oben, vermisst seine Frau, seine Kinder und so weiter und irgendwann drehte ich mich um und war da so eine Menschentraube von 50 Leuten hinter mir, die alle sehr erstaunt dann so schauten, was macht ihr denn da, ja, ISS hier gerade zuhören und versuchen durchzukommen. War schon ziemlich guter Spaß, vor allen Dingen, als dann hinterher Holgi, dein Vorgänger quasi fürs Chaosradio dann auch mal auf mich zukam, meinte so, boah, ich hab noch nie die ISS gesehen und jetzt hab ich sie so gleich noch gehören sogar dazu. Das sagten schon einige und ich werde heute immer noch wieder drauf angesprochen von einigen Leuten, ich war mit dem Camp dabei, als du die ISS gehört hattest.
Das ist echt sehr cool. Aber noch eine andere Paragraph-Probe zuhören, ihr habt ja gesagt, man braucht ja diese Genehmigung, muss die Prüfung ablegen, weil man mit dem Equipment tatsächlich also irgendwie Taxi, Schiff, Flug, was auch immer Funk irgendwie hören kann und auch weiß, dass man dann nicht reinsenden darf, dem zuzuhören?
Könnte.
Könnte, darf man nicht oder wie?
Es ist auch tatsächlich so, dass es ja eine Funkaussendung, die nicht für die Öffentlichkeit bestimmt ist und auch kein Amateurfunk ist und deswegen darf ich das weder bewusst hören noch die Frequenzen ansteuern, noch darüber reden, ob und was ich da gehört habe. Selbst die Tatsache, dass ich sowas mal gehört habe, darf ich nicht kommunizieren.
Also die Frage, wäre sowas interessant, wenn man jetzt zufällig da drauf stößt, kann da wahrscheinlich nicht beantwortet werden?
Na also Amateurfunk, die Bänder und die Frequenzen, dafür darfst du ja mithören.
Nein, ich meine, bei den, egal, lassen wir das, Global Response und so.
Bei dem anderen habe ich noch nie reingehört, also ich habe noch nie mein Funkgerät irgendwie mal auf Behördenfunk oder was anderes eingestellt, außer Schiffsfunk, aber das darf ich auch machen, weil ich auch eine Lizenz dafür habe.
Das ist bei Flugfunk noch ganz lustig, also in Deutschland ist es tatsächlich untersagt, Flugfunk zu hören, in anderen Ländern ist das anders, deswegen gibt es im Internet auch Streams davon. Ob man jetzt in Deutschland legal einen Stream aus den USA hören kann, weiß ich nicht. Aber das Gesetz in Deutschland ist tatsächlich sogar so stark, dass selbst ein Pilot in seiner Freizeit den Flugfunk nicht abhören darf, weil er in dem Moment ja nicht im Dienst oder nicht in der Funktion als Pilot unterwegs ist und der Flugfunk tatsächlich nur für den Betrieb, für den Flugbetrieb benutzt werden darf. Abhören.
Keinen, keinen Dienstfunk, aber mal mit der ISS-Funktion, das macht Amateurfunk möglich. Ich finde es total super. Wir hören jetzt noch, bevor wir uns mal mit, also natürlich an der wichtigsten Thema, welche Hardware kann ich wie kaufen und selber löten beschäftigen, noch eine kleine Musik.
Hier ist das Spandau-Relay DB0SP, bitte sprechen Sie.
Letzte halbe Stunde im Chaosradio 224, wo wir heute über Amateurfunk reden. Und das Coolste wurde mir fast bis zum Schluss vorgehalten, dass man nämlich, wenn man Amateurfunk, sogar mit der ISS sprechen kann und den Astronauten, die da drauf sind. Und die andere coole Sache, die natürlich bei jedem Hobby total wichtig ist, ist die Hardware, die man sich anschaffen kann. Ihr habt es schon erzählt, dass man irgendwie, wie war das mit einem grafitbestäubten Hühnerdarm auch irgendwie funken kann und einer kleinen Drahtrolle und so. Aber es ist ja immer so, man will auch so ein bisschen coole Geräte haben. Und ich sehe auch, also hier steht so ein Ding auf dem Tisch, das hat ein Farbdisplay und ein großes Rad und leuchtende Knöpfe und cooles Zeug. Was gibt es denn so für Hardware? Worauf musst du denn achten? Was kann man denn da ein Geld ausgeben? Und was davon will man selber löten?
Ausgeben so viel wie du hast.
Natürlich.
Es gibt da so die schönen Altsprüche, bringe deinen Kindern Amateurfunk bei und sie werden kein Geld für Drogen haben.
Okay, es gibt selbst Basteln, dann gibt es diese Handfunkgeräte. In welchen Preisklassen spielt sie das an?
Das kommt halt darauf an, was du möchtest. In den letzten Jahren gibt es sehr viel China-Plastikware, die qualitativ nicht so super dolle ist und auch ein bisschen neben der Optorequenz sendet, aber alles noch im Rahmen des zugelassenen. Das sind Handfunkgeräte, wie wir sie... Ich komme jetzt gerade einfach dran.
Hier zum Beispiel eine solche. Das ist so eine Bauaufengquetsche.
Bauaufeng ist der Markenname von den Dingern.
Für die Leute, die jetzt nicht den Video-Stream gucken, das sind tatsächlich Handgross ungefähr. Wie so ein Hocky-Tocky. Also kleiner als ein Smartphone. Also kleiner, aber viel, viel breiter.
Und was die meistens machen, ist es auf 2, 70 Meter, also in diesem 144 MHz und 430 MHz-Bereich senden und empfangen. Das ist so das, was wir eben schon als Quasselfunk bezeichnet haben, was so die Relais machen, wo man so untereinander reden kann. Und was so oft einfach auch Koordination ist, wo man sich morgens so mit seinem Ortsverband irgendwie kurz abspricht oder abends unterhält, was man so den Tag über gemacht hat oder so. Oder eben Kurzwelle verabredet, so was man da mal versuchen kann oder sich austauscht. Wie ist denn jetzt hier in Berlin gerade, wie sind die Bedingungen eigentlich für die Kurzwelle aus Berlin jetzt gerade? Wer kam denn heute bis wohin? Wie sind die Ausbreitungsbedingungen? Die liegen so bei, ich glaube, 30, 40 Euro.
30, 40 Euro ist man dabei mit hier so einem kleinen, ja, bekommt man bei Amazon.
Genau. Dann gibt es günstige Geräte zum Einbau ins Auto. Ich habe mir jetzt auch letzte Woche aus Frust eins gekauft. Das ist auch nicht wirklich größer als ein Handfunkgerät. Kann dann allerdings schon 10 Watt. Die Handfunkgeräte können 3 bis 5. Das kann dann 10 Watt Ausgangsleistung. Sie verbrauchen auch sehr wenig Strom und können am Schreibtisch liegen und nebenbei mitlaufen. So dass man eben auf diesen lokalen Frequenzen drauf ist und auf den Relais mithören kann und empfangsbereit ist. Das ist ganz nett. Das ist aber alles und keine Kurzwelle. Wenn du in den Bereich gehst, sind das schon ein paar hundert Euro, die du ausgeben möchtest.
Ja und dann haben wir noch keine Antennen dazu und noch keine Kabel und noch das ganz andere schöne Zubehör, was man sich dazu klicken kann.
Wobei, das günstigste sind die Antennen, die kann man auch sehr schnell aus alten Lautsprecherkabeln zusammenbauen.
Genau, ich halte das mal für den Stream auch hoch.
Das ist halt simpel, man nimmt sich hier so eine Aufputzdose, baut da noch ein bisschen kleine Technik rein. Also, manchmal reicht es auch nur aus dort ein Anschlusskabel reinzulegen, man macht das halt nur in eine Aufputzdose, weil die Wetterfest ist eine Regel und dann stinkt normales Lautsprecherkabel, das reicht dann aus, um auch mal 100 Watt drüber zu senden, ohne dass es direkt verspülst. Der Nachteil bei Kurzwelle ist einfach, die Antenne muss größer sein. Die kann ich jetzt nicht mal eben so in die Hosentasche stecken, wie ich es so mit Handfunkgeräten machen kann, die ja so einen kleinen Gummiburst oben drauf haben, sondern muss schon in der Regel etwas größer sein. Das ist halt das Problem, dass sie auch nicht so gerne mobile oder portabel eingesetzt werden.
Und kann man sich diese mehrere Hundert Euro Geräte auch selber bauen?
Darfst du, ja, kannst du auch machen. Es gibt auch Leute, die das machen, die sich dahinter klemmen und dann wirklich alles zusammenlöten. Die gibt es auch als Bausatz zu kaufen.
Sind die dann wesentlich billiger?
Nicht mehr allzu viel. Das ist dann auch wieder so eine kleine Gesetzeslücke in Deutschland. Da muss dann dafür keine Entsorgungsgebühr bezahlt werden. Wenn du fertige Geräte verkaufst, musst du halt irgendwie so eine Umweltgebühr bezahlen.
Das ist der einzige Unterschied aber.
Das ist meist der einzige Unterschied. Und meistens heißt Bausatz in dem Fall jetzt auch nur, du steckst die Platine in ein Gehäuse und schraubst es zu. Gut, früher war das anders.
Das liegt halt daran, dass die ganzen Bauteile in so einem Funkgerät, gerade wenn es jetzt aus China kommt oder so, hochgradig integriert sind. Also zum Beispiel so ein Bauffäng-Antgerät, da ist nicht mehr viel irgendwie an einzeln diskretem Aufbau drin, da hast du kaum noch Oszillatoren separat. Das ist alles ein Chip, da hast du quasi deinen Sound-Input und auf der anderen Seite dein Hochfrequenz-Output, der Hochfrequenz-Output geht an die Antenne und dann hast du vielleicht noch ein bisschen Spannung dran, ein bisschen Regelwerk und das war's dann im Prinzip schon.
Aber kann man das noch sozusagen diskret machen?
Ja klar, auf jeden Fall.
Für diese Morsen rund um die Welt mit wenig Leistung, das machen Leute, die bauen das überleben dann in so ein kleines Metallgehäuse, bauen sich dann den Oszillator und ihre HF-Stufe zusammen und dann kann man damit auch schon morsen und die kosten dann auch nicht ein paar hundert Euro. Aber wenn ich jetzt das Gerät nehme, was hier vor mir steht, das hat dann schon diese Digi-Modes drin, da kann ich einen Rechner anschließen, da kann ich direkt dieses Fernschreiben darüber machen, das kann das auch schon auswerten und schickt das seriell an den Rechner schon ausgewertet. Das hat dann Speicherplätze für die ganzen Relais drin oder für andere Frequenzen. Ich kann das Fernsteuern, ich kann das Display irgendwie mit einem Verlängerungskabel woanders betreiben. Das sind halt alles so Komfort-Features, die dann irgendwann Geld kosten.
Wie viel?
Ich glaube, das geht so für 700 Euro über die Ladentheke.
Noch, und das ist schon zehn Jahre alt. Na gut, ich habe im Keller zum Beispiel hier noch ein Funkgerät liegen, was ich wieder aufrüste. Das ist jetzt 48 Jahre alt. Das ist ein Röhrenfunkgerät. Das ist auch komplett von Hand zusammengebaut. Es kam als Einzelplatinensätze mit Bausatzteilen. Und das brauch ich jetzt mal in so einer kleinen Kondensatorkur. Die Kondensatoren müssen mal ausgetauscht werden. Die Röhren müssen mal überprüft werden und teilweise ausgetauscht werden. Die kriegst du aber noch recht gut auf Flohmärkten oder irgendwie im Internet halt. Röhren sind halt Verbrauchsprodukte. Die gehen halt irgendwann kaputt auch. Aber das ist auch noch heute einsatzfähig. Ich kann damit genauso noch die Sprache übertragen. Ich kann genauso gut noch damit morsen. Und die Frequenzen haben sich auch nicht geändert. Hier sind ein paar hinzugekommen noch. Aber die klassischen Amateurfunk-Frequenzen sind seit Anfang der 20er Jahre dieselben.
Fabienne, wie ist das denn in den USA? Spielt ihr da in ähnlichen Preisregionen ab? Oder habt ihr eure Autofunkgeräte selbst gebastelt?
Ja, ich war neidisch auf der alten Vintage Heat Kit von Lars. Ich habe mich auch eins gekauft in Ebay. Ich baue jetzt als Projekt eine Rohren Vintage 100 Watt Transceiver Radio, wo man so reden und morsen kann. Mein Traum ist, dass ich mit Lars reden kann.
Das ist unsere Challenge, dass wir beide mal die Rohrenfunkgeräte fertig kriegen und darüber über Kurzwelle uns austauschen können.
Das ist so zukunftlich, das ist das Ziel sozusagen. Aber dazu habe ich so viel Spaß, weil die alten Geräte, diese Heat Kits, die kommen mit so einer komplette Pakete, wie man das baut und warum und wie man das testet. Das ist nicht nur ein Kit von heute, wo man einfach mal die Dinge durch die Löcher löten und dann das klappt. Es gibt so viele Dinge, wo man das selbst tun muss. Ich finde das sehr schön. Das ist ein sehr schöner Teil und ein schöner Projekt. Aber in den USA haben wir auch viele Kits. Ich habe auch so eine QRP, eine sehr kleine Dinge, die passt in eine Altwades-Mint-Tin-Dings. Dann macht man mit einem kleinen Draht hoch und dann kann man, ich glaube das ist ein 80 Meter Morse-QRP-Dings und das kostet 5 Dollar oder so was. Das ist so sehr klein, das kostet gar nichts. Das macht viel Spaß. Ich habe viel Spaß in Antennen zu bauen, so selbst zu bauen. Es gibt viele Infos im Internet und leider auch viele Infos, die nicht mehr im Internet sind seit zehn Jahren. In den USA ist es so, dass die Funke älter und älter wird und trotzdem die sterben, leider. Und es gibt so Webseite, die nicht mehr online sind, wo Leute ja nicht mehr im Leben sind eigentlich. Leider traurig, traurige Weise. Aber ich versuche mal, so viel von dieser Antenne How-To's wieder im Internet zu machen. Und es gibt auch ein sehr schönes Buch. Wie heißt das, Lars, diese Vintage Antennen Buch von Deutschland?
Jetzt erwischt mich gerade auf den falschen Fuß. Mir liegt es auf der Zunge, ich sag's gleich.
Wir reichen in ein zweites Mal nach in den Shownotes auf chaosradioccc.de. Wo das gerade gesagt wurde, viele alte Funke, die langsam wegsterben, ihr habt ja auch vorher gesagt, das Klischee will es, dass Amateurfunk eine alte Männergeschichte ist. Wir müssen jetzt tatsächlich bis in die USA telefonieren, um eine Frau dabei zu haben, die funkt. Ist das exemplarisch, ist das wirklich so?
Ganz kurz eingeschoben, das Buch heißt Drothammel für die Shownotes. Wie ist Amateurfunk? Es ist ganz häufig so, dass es ein alter Männersport ist oder Hobby. Hier in Berlin ist der Durchschnitt der Funkamateure, zumindest der organisierten, also die im Verein auch drin sind, ungefähr die Hälfte oder zwei Drittel von denen sind im Verein in Berlin und da ist das Durchschnittsalter 60. Deutschlandweit ist es noch ein bisschen höher, ich glaube das liegt momentan bei 63 in etwa und es ist ganz schwierig, gerade wieder Jugendgruppen aufzubauen. Es gab große Jugendgruppen in den 70ern und 80ern, da wurde halt das Löten beigebracht und so weiter und so fort. Die sind halt alle irgendwann mal eingegangen, weil ja, dann gab es Internet und Mobilfunk und halt so die ganzen Gründe, warum Amateurfunk eingegangen ist und jetzt heutzutage ist das Problem, dass die Schule halt sehr stark fordert oder die anderen Vereine mit Sport und sonst wie auch immer. Das Interesse ist auch nicht mehr ganz so groß bei einigen, aber es gibt einige wenige und da macht es auch Spaß mit denen zusammenzuarbeiten.
Also Beispiel DK0TU zum Beispiel, eine TU Berlin, das sind sehr sehr viele sehr junge Leute, die das neu wieder aufgebaut haben vor ein paar Jahren.
Aber junge Leute oder junge Männer?
Beides.
Also es sind unter 30. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie viele Frauen ihr bei euch im Ausverband habt, ich weiß da sind ein paar.
Wir sind ja organisiert in einem sogenannten Ausverband Freunde des CCC, das heißt wirklich als Gruppe von CCC-Funkern. Wir haben eine relativ hohe Quote von 50 Prozent Frauen.
Okay, 50 Prozent ist relativ hoch. Fabienne, wie ist das denn? Ist das in den USA auch so ein eher alter Männersport?
Das passt zu, wo man ist. In Seattle es gibt viele Frauen, es gibt 50 Prozent Frauen. Aber das ist nicht überall in den USA. In Tennessee war da so vielleicht 20 Prozent Frauen. Aber ja, das gehört zu. Texas ist auch wenige Frauen. In Kalifornien es gibt viele Frauen. Ich glaube, das verbindet sich an, wo die technische Ort in den USA sind. So Seattle und Kalifornien und ja, da sind viele technische Leute und gehört dazu viele technische Frauen. Und deswegen, ich glaube, die Interesse da so höher ist. Und eine Freundin von mir hat so eine Haus vier Straßen weiter von mir und die hat gerade frische seine neue Lizenz seit paar Wochen. Es gibt auch Frauen, die neue Lizenz bekommen, aber es gibt auch Frauen in Seattle, die älter sind, die sind so 50, 60 Jahre alt. Die Frauen, die sind auch nicht so die neue Gruppe.
Aber es gibt ja das Klischee und oft genug sagen, also man hört das noch aus dem GEMA-Bereich sozusagen, da gibt es auch Frauen, aber wenn die damit an die Öffentlichkeit treten, werden die oft schlecht behandelt. Sind Funka da irgendwie netter oder muss man da als Frau sich auch sagen vorsehen, wenn man irgendwie auf die Antenne kommt, dass man dann...
Ich würde sagen, es ist viel einfacher, wenn ich so Contests mache, die wollen so mit Frauen reden. So es ist einfacher, wenn da ein Pile ist, so wenn viele Leute mit jemandem weit weg reden will. So zum Beispiel, ich bin in den USA und die Leute sind in Europa, die wollen mit Frauen reden. So wenn du so eine Frau auf dem Radio mit deinen Rufzeichen, dann kommt die direkt an dir und die sagen, manchmal die sagen, ja, the YL, die junge Dame mit den Rufzeichen, blablabla. So es gibt auch kurze Dinge, so YLOM, YL bedeutet young lady, und OM bedeutet old man, und es gibt kein young man und es gibt kein old woman. So es ist ein bisschen so drangebaut in die Sprache, würde ich sagen. Aber es gibt nicht so, Leute sind nett, würde ich sagen.
Okay, das ist ja schön zu hören. Ich würde noch mal zurück zu der Hardware kommen, und zwar sind ja die Funkgeräte, über die wir jetzt gesprochen haben, die sagen, die sind ja alle auf bestimmte Frequenzen irgendwie abgestimmt und sind auch teuer und zu bauen, der höchste Traum ist das alte Transistoren-Ding, das man noch aufbauen kann. Aber ihr habt gesagt, man kann, stimmt, Röhrendings, ihr habt ja gesagt, man kann auch mit einem DVB-T-Stick Amateurfunk. Naja, zumindest mal auf jeden Fall hören. Was steckt dahinter? Ist doch irgendwas mit Basteln und DVB-T-Sticks auseinandernehmen?
Ja, das geht natürlich schon. Funken nicht unbedingt, es gibt welche, die funken können, aber DVB-T ist nichts anderes als ich empfange einfach Signale. Und die werden aber nicht komplett über den Stick aufgewertet, sondern ich stecke ja einen Rechner dahinter. Wir stecken in unsere USB-Schnittstelle rein und dekodiere dort das Signal erst. Das heißt, das Einzige, was da drin ist, ist ein Empfänger, mehr nicht.
Was halt passiert ist, diese DVB-T-Sticks, auch im normalen Betrieb, senden im Prinzip nur das, was sie auf dem Hochrequenzteil empfangen. Das ist dann irgendwie kodiert an den Rechner. Der Rechner rechnet da das DVB-T-Signal raus, holt sich dann den Transponder raus und dekomplimiert dann das digital übertragene Fernsehbild und den Ton. Die Dinge haben aber einen relativ weiten Frequenzbereich und nicht nur den DVB-T-Bereich. Was auch daran liegt, dass weltweit die Frequenzen ein bisschen unterschiedlich sind und diese Chips einfach sehr hohe Bandbreite haben. Breitbandig, so wollte ich sagen. Und deswegen kann man die auf einem sehr hohen Frequenzbereich einstellen, weil sie auch Radioempfang haben. Das heißt, das geht bei 60-70 MHz los, geht oben bis 2 Gigahertz oder so, weil sie auch Kabel-TV und Satelliten-TV empfangen können. Und man kann dann mit Software auch andere Dinge dekodieren, zum Beispiel Sprache, die auf anderen Frequenzbändern sind.
Aber das heißt, das macht nicht die Software, die bei diesen Dingen mitgeliefert wird, sondern da muss man selber hacken.
Das macht nicht die Software, die da mitgeliefert wird. Es gibt allerdings mittlerweile jede Menge Software und Treiber, auch zum Beispiel unter Linux oder so was, mit denen das dann geht. Und wo wir beim Senden waren, ich war vorhin ganz kurz bei DK0TU, die machen gerade auch noch einen Kurs. Und da haben sie Raspberry Pi's genommen und haben über den GPIO-Port auf 433 Megahertz analog, digital getastet, Sprache ausgesendet, was man mit einem normalen Funkgerät empfangen konnte. Das war schon ein bisschen scary und es waren halt drei Bauteile an so einem GPIO-Pin dran.
Okay, aber nochmal zurück in die DVB-T-Sticks. Also da kann ich theoretisch mit einer Software zulegen, die es mir erlaubt, mit Hilfe eines normalen DVB-T-Sticks Amateurfunk zu hören. Darf ich das?
Also du kannst dir hier diese DVB-T-Sticks im Prinzip vorstellen wie eine Soundkarte. Also Soundkarte hat man ja heutzutage standardweise, das ist auf dem Rechner drin. Die geht normalerweise von irgendwie sowas von 20 bis 20.000 Hertz. So und so ein DVB-T-Stick, das ist ein sogenanntes Software Defined Radio da drin und dieser Chip, der das dann halt diese Signale sampelt, man hört dann eben nicht auf 20 bis 20.000 Hertz, sondern zum Beispiel auf, sagen wir mal, irgendwie sowas wie 100 Megahertz, 200 Megahertz bis ein paar Gigahertz hoch und nimmt das im Prinzip genau diese Wellen dann auf und leitet das dann roh an den Rechner weiter. Und was der Rechner dann macht, das hängt dann eben von der Software ab, wo man dann hingehen kann und dann diese aufgenommenen Töne sozusagen in ein entsprechendes Signal dann wieder demoduliert. Alles rein in Software.
Das Spannende ist einfach bei dem Radio, was es beim letzten Chaos Communication Camp gab. Das ist nicht nur ein Empfänger wie so ein DVT-Stick, sondern auch ein Sender. Also das heißt, ich kann auch damit die Signale aufbreiten.
Um das Radio nochmal zu sagen, genau, das ist also ein Bausatz?
Das ist das Radio, naja Bausatz in dem Sinne, ich stecke ein Display drauf und eine Batterie und dann ist es fertig.
Okay, das ist fertig. Also ein kleines Funkgerät.
Genau, richtig, es ist ein kleines Funkgerät, womit ich dann auch wieder Sachen senden kann.
Aber nicht darf?
Kommt drauf an, es gibt ja auch Frequenzbereiche, wo ich auch offen senden darf. Also wo alle quasi so ein bisschen senden dürfen, aber halt nur mit geringer Leistung.
Wo sie die Thermometer, Punktthermometer und der ganze Kram und Garagentur öffnen und sowas.
Das sogenannte ISM-Band.
Oder auch bis 10 Milliwatt darf ich ja auch zum Beispiel im Radiobereich senden. Das sind dann diese kleinen Sender, die ich im Auto früher mitführen konnte oder heute immer noch, dass ich mein Handy übers Radio empfangen kann quasi. Das ist ja dann irgendwann aufgeweicht worden vor zehn Jahren, glaube ich war das in etwa, dass ich auch da kleine Sender verwenden darf. Also mit wenig Leistung, wie das Radio auch macht, darf ich auch mit senden.
Da kann man sich zum Beispiel auch was hier mit dem Raspberry Pi basteln. Das ist so was, was du gerade meintest, nämlich da diese GPIO Pins, die kann man halt entsprechend auch mit 100 Megahertz, naja, an und aus machen und dadurch entsprechend halt mit einem kleinen Tiefpassfilter noch dahinter, naja, senden.
Das lassen wir dann technisch versiert. Ich würde jetzt sozusagen, weil wir bald am Ende der Sendung sind, noch mal genau fragen wollen, es gibt ja, du machst ja Lars diesen Kurs hier im Chaos Computer Club Berlin, er ist gerade vorbei, glaube ich, oder? Was soll noch einen geben? Bitte sagen Sie jetzt, wenn jemand diese zwei Stunden durchgestanden hat und denkt so, yes, Amateurfunk, ich möchte das auch machen und bin auch in Berlin.
Genau, ich gebe hier regelmäßig Kurse in Berlin. Das heißt, der nächste ist so geplant für ab Herbst, also so Oktober rum. Das ist auch wieder zeitgleich, so wie es aussieht, mit dem Kurs in der TU Berlin. Das wird zeitgleich starten, aber wir sind genügend Leute, dass wir uns auch aufteilen können, das passt schon. Also meistens gibt es genügend Anmeldungen. Vielleicht muss ich die auch irgendwann schließen, weil nicht so viele Leute hier reinfassen in den Raum. Es wird aber vermutlich noch mal im Sommer einen Kurs in Berlin geben. Das steht noch nicht ganz fest, der dann so ein Sommerferien-Intensivkurs ist, um das instelle halt durchzubeitschen, das ganze Thema. Ansonsten, wer jetzt nicht aus Berlin ist, hoffentlich sind auch noch andere Zuhörer da. Und Zuhörerinnen natürlich. Es gibt in vielen Hackspaces Kurse. Es gibt bei sogenannten Ortsverbänden vom Deutschen Amateur Radio Club Kurse. Es gibt die Online-Kurse, wer jetzt halt gerade keine Zeit hat, irgendwo lokal hinzugehen, kann auch so einen Online-Kurs mit besuchen und dort dann halt regelmäßig Briefe zugeschickt kriegen, also E-Mails in diesem Fall. Oder einfach selbstständig lernen, das geht auch.
Okay, dann kommen wir jetzt wirklich zum Ende der Sendung. Und ich würde von euch sozusagen noch mal, ihr habt jetzt für die Famous Last Words sozusagen jede Gelegenheit und noch mal sozusagen in einem Satz zusammenfassen, was an Amateurfunk ist so toll, dass ihr es anderen Leuten auch weiterempfehlen würdet. Fabienne, ich würde gerne mit dir anfangen.
Ja, bei mir, das ist, ich glaube, für Leute, das ist so ein breiter Hobby. Da wird man immer so Spaß haben, die nächsten 50 Jahre und fang einfach mal an und find jemand, die dich was erklären kann und lernt mal was und ja, ich finde das toll.
War das eine Abkürzung, die ich jetzt verstehen müsste nach diesen zwei Stunden?
Oh ja, 73 heißt viele Grüße, das hört sich im Morsen einfach toll an und deshalb nutze ich das auch und das war dann ihr Rufzeichen. Ich mache Amateurfunk, weil ich einfach den Spaß daran habe, dass ich ohne Provider mit so einer Antenne im Garten durch die Welt funken kann oder zu Raumschiffen oder zum Mond und so weiter. Also das ist für mich der große Spaß, dann auch die Sachen zusammen zu bauen.
Ja, im Prinzip auch, dass ich eben ohne irgendeinen Mittelsmann dazwischen, der mich in der Kommunikation beschränkt, noch mit Leuten reden kann und ja Technik selber bauen kann, die funktioniert und da eben mein Wissen anwenden kann.
Ja genau, für mich steht da auch eindeutig das Basteln und der Spaß an der Technik im Vordergrund. Ja und in diesem Sinne 73 auch von mir, Delta Delta 4, Mike Delta.
Ja dann vielen Dank, ich habe immer noch kein Rufzeichen ausgedacht, aber ich bin tatsächlich auch noch so ein bisschen hin und her gerissen, weil einerseits mit der ISS funken, das klingt schon ziemlich cool und rumbasteln, andererseits irgendwie so diese ganze Technik und Juristerei auch lernen müssen, mehrere Monate. Ich fürchte mein Durchhaltevermögen reicht nicht, das es nach diesen zwei Stunden erstmal schöpft. Ich bedanke mich aber auf jeden Fall bei Fabienne, Lars, Mutags und Matthias fürs Mitmachen und Erzählen, was Amateurfunk so ist, bei den Show Notes, die während der Sendung die Show Notes geschrieben haben, bei Danimo, der sich um die ganze Technik gekümmert hat. Dann bleibt mir nur noch zu sagen, vielen Dank, dass ihr zugehört habt beim Chaosradio 224. Die nächste Ausgabe gibt es dann wieder von Fritz aus Potsdam. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter, mir bleibt nur noch zu sagen, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.